hey guys do you like charity
gamers we have a big announcement we are
going to be doing a 24-hour charity
stream you heard that right so the world
situation kind of messed up right now
for all sorts of different reasons so we
thought we would come together stream
for 24 hours to support doctors without
borders on our twitch channel twitch.tv
slash trash taste podcast what are we
going to be doing on that stream though
is the question you're probably asking
games
we have a bunch of different things
planned including guests games and
humiliation and joan will eat a ghost
pepper maybe who knows if we maybe
maybe so make sure to open up that
wallet to make sure that joey can suffer
that's that's the reason we're doing it
i'm not here for the charity i'm here to
make joey suffer
so the event will be starting 11 a.m
japan time on the 19th of march uh if
you live anywhere else in the world here
are some just basic time zones that
hopefully mood on is putting on screen
right now if not look it up yourself on
time converter but yeah it'll be going
on 24 hours and uh we'll hopefully
change the world for the better even for
a little bit and on with the episode
wait you're not gonna you're gonna solve
it you're gonna solve it joey no because
i need a [ __ ] but like it'll just
[Music]
welcome poop enthusiasts to another
episode of trash taste podcast i'm poop
enthusiast one with poop inside i'm not
a poop enthusiast i'm a bidet enthusiast
there's a difference you literally just
said god i need a [ __ ] no i don't i need
the second one i hope that's the first
second of this episode the same way you
need to yeah i'm not getting into this
guy i don't wanna i don't even wanna
humor this clown right
what have you been up to
pooping pooping
doing a lot of pooping
huh uh not playing final fantasy like an
idiot for [ __ ] sake joe for [ __ ]
sake joey i called
okay okay okay like i remember so we
record the episode where joey's like
gone don't play final fantasy 14. i
think it was like four weeks ago yeah
yeah and i'm like i'm like okay joey
you're a good mate i will trust you uh
and then and then what happens i uh get
i get a condition in which i need to
stay in the house every day for about
two weeks straight okay um and i have
nothing to do because i'm not well
enough to work so what i do first i i
complete 13 sentinels uh which is uh oh
you finished it i i finished it and then
uh it was good it was as [ __ ] insane
as you said it was good and then i sit
there twiddling my thumbs going
oh what now
what do i do now and then i look at the
date and i look at twitter and uh final
fantasy 14 comes back on back on sale to
the public and i'm just like and i'm
just like i don't like either this is a
sign from god or the devil either one
definitely the devil either one it's a
sign the only way to get you guys to do
anything is be like don't do this don't
don't don't don't watch this don't play
this game you don't like it was that the
problem was that i was i was being too
negative i had to do the opposite i
didn't watch arcane this week right
just saying that's it
that's it i tell that's all i'm saying
that's so funny i didn't either yeah
that's crazy yeah right yeah [ __ ]
couldn't be me yeah i mean talking about
addiction joey i i see
i see i mean you you recently got into a
new gacha game as well
yeah well we mentioned it very briefly
in the last episode yeah yeah it's just
like the week where we just what am i
going to start heroin this week as well
i mean
alex's anonymous everything just goes
wrong i mean you've recently just been
addicted to uh torturing yourself
i want to be done with it i'm trying to
finish oh you're definitely addicted to
it i'm not i'm not i'm not i don't like
hurting myself you're like a [ __ ]
mask
you don't like hurting yourself you say
after like your 10th jumping stream it's
like you're getting it and then getting
over it and then the pogo stick or i
can't what's up
pogo stuck that's it well first of all
i want to clarify i don't enjoy myself
but
i enjoy a challenge
sometimes challenges is that not just
mentally ill
challenges require us to go through some
uncomfortable feelings and challenges i
get that you know
challenges
no i get that sentiment but i think what
makes a challenge you know satisfying is
when you do it every now and then yeah
you know not
every stream well you know what you know
what i i had this like revelation where
i was sitting there and i was like you
know
nobody bets an eye if you spend 1 000
hours playing at fps yeah the moment you
put 10 hours into a shitty jumping game
everyone's like you've got a problem you
know what's up with that
well i still think putting a thousand
hours into an fps
you don't is you're not a gamer a
thousand hours into an fps is not over
how long i don't know like a month
okay no that is that is a problem that
is the first thing is there even a
thousand hours in a month
[Music]
it would be just under i think because
that would be a slight that would be a
different problem entirely if there was
no there is not yeah otherwise there is
what am i saying how many hours in a
month 720 hours yeah okay yeah so this
man is like in the hyperbolic time
chamber
youtube at 1.5 times speed
so i i feel like fps i can get it
because at least there's a bit more
variety than literally pressing a button
and pointing in the direction and uh
doing that for 10 hours straight i've
never had like my wrists hurt before
from gaming but during the space bar
games that that hurts my wrist actually
i don't know why that hurts yeah that is
carpal tunnel speedrun it's cause it's
like the same action over
i mean when i do beat it right that's
what i'm saying it's good content to
watch not to do well it's a great
youtube highlight yeah because then it's
done but when you're in the middle of it
you're like i don't know if i can do
this i'm gonna have a mental breakdown i
don't know if this can be done
markiplier did like seven youtube parts
i just gave up yeah i mean i mean like
how soul crushing that is i mean like
it's good content in the same way that
you know mr b saying pewdiepie a million
times yeah is good content you know but
you know i it's not exactly what i'd
call fun and it's definitely uh it's
it's definitely suffering that's not a j
i can you know bring back yeah so i you
know i'd be be all the junking dlc i'm
probably gonna do the the other one at
some point i might have done it by the
time this comes out i don't know who
knows but um
i finished playing it and i was like oh
my god thank god the challenge is over i
can finally rest yeah and i played
pokemon arceus
and like it was kind of difficult
but at no point did i ever think i can't
do this like well yeah of course it's a
pokemon game and i missed that i missed
that moment where i was like i don't
know if i can do this like this is so
difficult i need this see that's why
you're a gamer and i'm not because the
moment i see a part of the game where
i'm like i can't do this i'm like
guess i'll die
and i just don't do it but like when i
know someone else has done something i'm
like well i can do it then why don't you
play sifu then what's that oh
yeah seafood it's like a new game that
just came out which is kind of like
based on you know old-school martial
arts films and i've heard it's like
pretty damn hard and it's pretty damn
challenging uh it's like got i mean i
haven't i haven't played it yet but i've
seen other streamers and other people
talk about it and uh i mean i don't want
to use like the dark souls analogy
because everyone uses the [ __ ] dark
souls analogy like you know difficulty
didn't exist before dark souls but i
have heard that it is a challenging game
to get through what happens
i feel like dark souls is like nothing
compared to these these rage games right
but what i don't understand is okay you
say you want to go for a challenge ride
yeah you don't want to learn how to
speed run so speed running is a
different thing for me in time i don't
think so i think i think it's exactly
like i think speed running is closer to
the [ __ ] you're doing with jump king and
pogo stock than it is to do with so
challenging you know like just different
mechanically mechanical challenging
games
here's where this is where i think speed
running for me is like something that i
i mean i've enjoyed it i've done it in
the past i used to speed it up like cop
head
back when they had an exploit in the
game they removed and then it's like not
really fun to do because it takes a lot
longer now yeah yeah um yeah so i used
to enjoy doing it but i found that the
point was is like okay let's say you get
to a certain point yeah you get to a
really good time and you start shaving
off like micro seconds right if you're a
streamer
and you know you want to stream content
it becomes really difficult to to keep
saying like this is content over and
over again because i'm not a speedrunner
i'm trying to make content right right
and so
like if you if i'm trying to make like a
youtube channel i'm trying to make
highlights i can't be like jump king
speedrun highlights part 17 right it
just doesn't work like yeah right i mean
i i've also
with with like saying like pogo stuck or
jump king right when if i'm not speed
running i tried speed running jump king
i got a pretty good time i got 12
minutes i think i can do better but
again i'd have to grind it a bunch and
it's not that entertaining but having a
hard goal
that is like you have done it at this
point you're done you can stop that's
way more satisfying i think as a viewer
to watch right but also as a content
creator it's a lot better for like a
narrative in a video to have like i mean
i i think it's pretty simple to turn
speed running into content you just you
can you just set yourself a hard target
a hard number that you get like i like
when i say you should be doing
speedrunning content i don't mean like
you should be going for a [ __ ] world
record or anything but like you know
like maybe setting your goal to be like
all right if the world record is like 10
minutes in this game yeah then you know
my goal is to get a pb of 15 minutes oh
well then
yeah you could do that i mean like
ludwig did it with like some of the the
games like he did like can you be all of
jump king in an hour yeah yeah three all
three maps yeah that that's interesting
that's way more appealing to me than
trying to grind and get the best time
yeah very impressive of the people who
can do it i'm just not consistent enough
i mean it's [ __ ] hard this like these
i don't know man you've been pretty
[ __ ] consistent with all these like
hard hats yeah yeah i mean
you i think you're like one step away
you seem to have found a niche of just
yeah i will just do this one repetitive
thing that is this one mechanic in the
game and do it for 10 hours and i'm just
like sounds exactly like what a speed
runner because you know it's it's uh one
of those things i keep saying that when
i want to buy time like one of those
things it's one of those things one more
you basically can
you need perseverance to like an extreme
level for a lot of these games
and i feel that
um
most people would just think this is
stupid and i'm just like but i can see
like the micro improvements
right i feel the like tiny tiny
improvements every time i feel like this
is pure copium right now no it's not
okay okay it's not no no no you get
better okay okay because like i get that
for like say a mechanically intensive
game like sifu you know like dark souls
you would not be feeling this satisfied
if you weren't streaming this game no i
would never do it yeah
exactly right because it it isn't as
satisfying like like you're finding like
the micro
like the micro things that you find fun
about this game to try and cope with how
much of of like how much of a [ __ ] time
how much of a [ __ ] time you're having
while doing it but at least people are
watching you do it you know i'm not
the chat is the silver lining yeah yeah
but like okay so like jump king i
initially i thought i thought that it
was dumb i thought it was stupid i
thought it was unfair yeah
after playing it i think it's like
amazing i feel like it's like incred i'm
not kidding it's an amazing game would
you have said that though if you hadn't
beaten it no
absolutely not right i understand if if
you play it and you think it's unfair i
understand that but when you play those
games more and especially like okay pogo
stack is
not awful awful game not
you said that about junking like
literally two two three weeks ago right
i said jump screen was good this is
going to be polio's things when he beat
him
he's like best game ever made amazing
jump king
bang of visuals absolutely amazing
soundtrack
i do agree i do like the aesthetics of
jumping it's like a it's it's a package
you know yeah well i will hold my uh
yeah i will reserve my opinions because
uh by the time this episode comes out me
and joey will probably have already done
our jumping race um try and beat it
you gonna go for it yeah i mean if we
can sure but i think i mean probably not
on that race but personally yeah yeah if
i start something i'm going to finish it
yeah like if like i think this race is
going to be the reason why i came up
with the race idea is because uh you
know i like myself uh enough to not
torture myself on stream for
entertainment so i was like he dragged
me he just
me neither
but uh i think like i mean we've
probably already done it by the time
this episode's coming yeah but like as
of right now i think it's like we're
giving ourselves like maybe
four hours
uh just because god and i are incapable
of streaming for more than four hours in
any game i think 10 to 15 hours is a
good range of how long it might take you
right all right so that race we probably
won't be beat it but i think afterwards
once we get the idea then we'll probably
like individually do it and then try and
beat it it's weird because like games
like that they like trick you
into thinking that the only progress
that matters is how far you've gotten
where it's like
in games like jumping and stuff like
that you're gonna have to restart so
many times so it's not about how far you
can get it's how many times can you do
all of the jumps to the point where you
fell perfect yeah like can you do that
more consistent it kind of sounds like
speed running kind of yeah yeah
i mean i mean it is
at least with jump king you get a mental
break you know you can stop for a moment
and you can kind of like okay right pogo
stuck it doesn't stop the program
doesn't stop moving it's just awful so
like speed running yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i mean the more i think about it the
more i think about it
is just a speed running yeah it's it's a
speed running simulator yeah try it try
it it's one of those games that looks a
lot easier than it is for sure i mean
i've done like bennett foddy's getting
over it that's easy that's not like
co-op and stuff like that and i'm just
like even then i was just like i thought
getting over it was hard after playing
these games getting over it is like
medium not even like hard yeah i mean i
be getting over it in three hours
my first time
so
well i feel like you started with jump
king and then you
like i guess you downgraded to getting
over it you get the mindset it's not
about how good you are at the games
about getting the mindset to improve the
games
i feel like i feel like i could i just
i'll just go into like zen mode you need
zero zero range zero ranging from yeah
you can't you can't beat a game like
that while [ __ ] being like
i did
yeah
if you ever get to the top or the
castles yeah like the soundtracks are
like oh yeah i can imagine it but like i
see you guys have been playing pokemon a
lot as well yeah
that's all i have to do yeah so there's
like a lot of post post game so i've
heard like mixed things about arceus
which has stopped me from getting it
right now which is like i've heard like
it's a really fun game but it's just a
really empty world i mean
it's the best pokemon game we've had in
like five i don't [ __ ] know very long
a very long time i agree that's that's
like saying like this is the best big
mac i've ever had it's like
it's not that much it's way better than
the big bang down the road yeah this
isn't like saying that like ocarina of
time came before it in like the zelda
right yeah yeah yeah we haven't had a
fresh pokemon game in a long time i know
this is old news by the time this has
come out but i think it's still good to
recognize i mean i'm still playing it
i'm playing all the post game and i'm
doing all the side quests and everything
because i'm just that kind of gamer it
was hard it's a hard pokemon game it
gets very hard some of the battles are
hard as [ __ ] yeah it's kind of annoying
because it feels like
they revolutionized what they needed to
and somehow just completely like did
stupid choices for certain things right
they just like
make battles for like the first like two
thirds of the game just like
way too easy way too easy right and then
randomly they're like how about we just
uh [ __ ] you and they just start making
them really [ __ ] hard it's not only
it but the thing that i noticed is that
it's not just the fact that there's just
this immediate jump in the levels of the
pokemon but like i feel out of all the
pokemon games the ai in this game is so
[ __ ] cool oh yeah it's it's smart
it's very very smart so it's like they
do some moves where i'm just like that's
like competitive level pokemon right and
i'm just getting [ __ ] cause like i'm so
used to you know fighting like really
dumb npcs in pokemon games right like in
all the main line pokemon games yeah and
this this time around it's like uh uh
we're playing 5d chess now yeah and i
just get [ __ ] yeah i felt like in
previous pokemon games just knowing the
typings of the pokemon was enough to
like easily comfortably get yeah yeah
right whereas at the points in this game
i was like i know all the typings i just
can't beat this one guy like there's
this one fight in the game it's very
difficult right
and it took me like 10 attempts really
yeah
very frustrating so you can't just like
autopilot your way through the game and
you do have to after a certain point in
the game if you want to beat a cert
fight you do have to like yeah think and
grind and actually i doubt you'll do it
first time it's very difficult i managed
to do it first time but only because my
chat was like uh there's a hardest [ __ ]
fight coming up
so you better uh you better at least
like prepare and i'm like guys come on
[ __ ] easy whatever
i did i almost [ __ ] died i was like
oh okay i should probably uh i probably
go grind a little bit yeah but um yeah
no but uh like look i completely get why
people don't want to touch the game
because
when i first booted up the game i was
like god this looks like a ps2 game it
like doesn't it doesn't look great and
it doesn't run great graphically it
doesn't look great it runs like [ __ ] a
lot of the times especially if you're
like playing it through a capture card
like it's a little bit better i play it
a little bit on stream like on the
switch
and it plays okay right it's still not
amazing like it's still nowhere near as
like you know [ __ ] mario odyssey
levels of like frame rate or anything
like that but i think you get over it
very quickly because the gameplay is
just so refreshing yeah and fun and like
yeah i get the world is like empty or
whatever but people said it was empty
but that's like i mean the pokemon are
the thing that you give yeah exactly you
know i hated having to collect these
[ __ ] berries in the trees all the
time yeah i kept running out of
pokeballs
you know you could like go on a mount
but you can collect stuff on a mount so
you have to get off it to collect the
stuff and then immediately get back on
it you can collect stuff on a mountain
uh no you can't oh no no you can't yeah
no you can't you can
no you have to get off the mount
what oh oh like throwing it at a tree
yeah oh i thought you may just like
stuff on the ground oh stuff on the
ground yeah yeah yeah okay yeah sorry i
was like
what but like the best part of the game
is just catching pokemon they actually
like
recaptured that joy of being tan again
like but the moment when you can just
like be hiding in a a little shrub and
you just [ __ ] eat a pokeball just
across the field and you catch that
pokemon without noticing you is like the
best feeling
yeah and also like you can like let's
say you're level uh 30 you can catch a
level 70 pokemon with enough persistence
right if you just
just get very very lucky right which is
really fun and it's like really like oh
my god this is so exciting it's a hype
moment when you like catch level 70 at
level 30. but you can't control it so
but i mean it's still like really cool
so you can have these really strong
pokemon i felt like they had a good
range of pokemon they didn't just choose
the normal ones you expect i don't know
i think uh people were a bit too harsh
on it i think i agree yeah i think a
little people love it yeah because i
mean i get you know i get the whole
argument of like oh it's nintendo it's
game freak you know they should have a
billion gajillion dollars to put into
you know making a smooth game and giving
it the best graphics but it's like
i don't know i i i personally think that
like the graphical
choice i guess that they went i mean i
don't really care about story i don't
really care about graphics that much
mean either honestly honestly like i
don't either but they weren't noticeably
lacking i'd say yes
it wasn't that they weren't good it's
that they were like oh okay there were
definitely some moments where i'm like
oh that tree in the distance is freaking
out for no reason uh
let's just ignore that yeah but
there's good uh quality of life changes
i don't know it's pokemon right so when
they take they take one step forward and
then they just tear their leg off that's
what they do like they the moment they
have something good they start just
[ __ ] it up and i bet i hope that we
get more games like this because they
basically made it so that you don't need
to battle but also the battling is way
smoother there's not this animation
[ __ ]
happens you know you can run around you
can it's good but i know it's pokemon so
they're going to be like all right now
let's just get rid of that let's not do
that anymore and it's like why what's
wrong with you yeah i really hope that
i'm enough enough fans need to make it
[ __ ] operal for them to like bring
back us i don't know i feel like pokemon
fans are loud as [ __ ] i feel like it's
just pokemon companies doing their own
thing yeah that's usually like it's just
the pokemon company being like we can
make whatever the [ __ ] we want we know
you'll buy it yeah i mean they will i
mean pokemon's like the most profitable
yeah like franchise of all time for like
a reason right it's a fun game though
i'd say uh i think i said it was six or
seven six or seven yeah i'd give it like
yeah seven or eight i'd say well it's a
really refreshing considering i bought
the uh pearl and diamond remake and i
have barely had the motivation to even
put it in my switch i think yeah that
says a lot i know it's weird for me
right because as like as someone who
doesn't really have time to play games i
like if something's not like a nine or a
10 i very rarely go out and play it
unless i'm streaming it or making
content or something like that but how
would you know if it's a nine or a ten
if you don't play it um normally i just
watch reviews and watch and listen to
recommendations
i think
obviously the most trustable most
trustworthy the only game god has ever
played is ocarina of time
it is a light novel though as well so
that might get you into it yeah there's
a lot of darkness never shut the [ __ ] up
there's a lot of dialogue it's really
weird because it's like it takes me a
lot to get into a game sometimes it's
like i like i try i've tried to really
like narrow down what my taste in video
games is and the more i think about it
the more i'm just like i have no idea
because like okay so like with with
final fantasy 14 for example
like so i was playing that like i looked
here and there during like yeah uh
during when i was ill right and i
remember literally yesterday literally
yesterday right we were in the lift and
i turned to terry i'm like joey got to
be honest with you started final fantasy
14 right but you don't need to worry
joey i'm like it's it's not it's not
addicting at all like i'm i'm i'm i'm
like i'm like i i played it i've stopped
myself i'm good i'm good at it right
i shook his hand and everything too yeah
she shook my hand um and then i went
home and i'm just like
i don't really have anything to do maybe
i'll just like like because the thing is
it's just a nice comfort game for me to
like zone out and just you know tap
buttons um and then so i i booted up and
then i get into like my first like big
boss battle like big raid and then i
remember finishing the finishing the
raid i was like
oh no
that was really fun that was that was
really [ __ ] fun i need you to i want
to take back that handshake i gave you
that night
because i thought i thought we had like
established something you know there was
a there was a trust that was formed
there and he just ripped it away i was
just like oh i really really want to
continue playing now i look at the clock
i'm like it's midnight and we got a
trash chase recording in the morning i'm
like i'd go for another two hours okay
another hour or two i can squeeze how
much sleep do i need and like because he
hear his thing i've never like
i've i never really got into mmos right
i never i never went through a phase
where i got addicted to roon uh
runescape craft i was going to say
runecraft then runescape or wow
so this is like my first proper
mmo and like i wasn't really into it
because i thought like i didn't really
enjoy the gameplay because like the the
battle system for final fantasy
especially at the beginning was like
really [ __ ] basic it's like just
point at something and tap a button and
do like a basic three-hit combo and then
that's it and i was like you know i'm
here for the story i'm gonna stick here
for the story but uh then i experienced
the first raid i was like
you know that was that was pretty damn
fun um and i'm scared for myself now i
don't know i don't know i just i just
it's been a while since i've had the
experience of just having a moment in a
game and just having like this like i
guess like it felt i felt like a like a
like an ember had been lit just like i
want to experience that again that's
what i'm saying man like mmos are a lot
like like like quicksand yeah where it's
like the more you try to quit the more
you just get sucked in yeah i'm glad i
got it out of me when i was like yeah
i don't really have an urge to play mmos
at all yeah i mean like what what did
you guys find addicting about mmos when
you got into it i think the number one
thing that got me addicted which i'm
glad you haven't experienced yet per se
is when you have like a large group of
friends that you see often who also play
out
where like it's just like like i had
like a group of like three or four mates
like during the runescape hero and or
like the maple story here that i could
just like ring up on skype and just be
like all right so uh sesh for like seven
hours and like yeah yeah let's do it and
then you just play it while you're in a
conversation and it's the the best way
to kill time
but at the same time it's like you
finish that seven hour session and
you're like
what have i just done
yeah i think it's a game where like the
goals or for me at least felt like they
were
uh
there was never
a never-ending supply of goals yeah
mm-hmm
whereas in like a game like i don't know
if i if i do this the campaign in a card
or something yeah i'm done in hours yeah
but in runescape it just like never
ended and every time i i hit a milestone
and i i got more cool quests i could do
wow that's so sick oh i got this really
badass item okay and so like every time
you're you're grinding towards something
you always just kind of unlock these
cool things that were just enough
serotonin boost to keep you being like
invested a lot yeah and even when you
finish through like all those side
quests for example
you see one player that just walks past
your play and you go i want what he has
yeah how do i get that and then now your
quest is to be that yeah exactly right
it just never ends right and then also
like i don't know if you can do this in
final fantasy but in runescape you could
lose like all your stuff
really yeah you could just lose like
yeah escape by dying yeah by getting
killed
like i've died of [ __ ] time i've not
lost nothing so thank you
see there you go
i don't know i don't see mmo i i i've
killed in your hand i feel like i
couldn't i wouldn't be able to get into
like runescape a while then because like
one of the big factors i feel like into
video games is like i need a i need a
reason to keep playing and most of that
reason is storyline like gameplay loop a
lot of the time that's not enough of a
reason to keep me invested in
me invested in the game for like long
term um having said that your thing
about the mates thing like when i was
when i was doing this boss battle i was
like
i wonder how fun this would be with
friends to do it but at the same time
they're gonna do that they're gonna be
that guy who like can't join us today
because he has a raid or something yeah
yeah he has an event raid that's only
available during these hours
um but yeah i mean this is this is i
guess the start of i don't know what
yeah it just maybe on my stream it who
knows you know how before you were
saying that like uh viewers of trash
taste could tell when we record these
episodes based on my hair yeah that now
they're going to be able to tell based
on the size of his eye bags
that are going to be forming from
endless nights of final fantasy 14. it's
like it's like oh man they're like this
far down now he's like you finished
three raids
i think i also stay away from them
because my little brother was like
addicted to world of warcraft yeah yeah
and i could like just see how much he
would play
it and to like no avail yeah exactly at
the end of it he was just like yeah it
wasn't that fun
after like years of playing yeah well of
course it's like it's like you know
every [ __ ] league player or like
overwatch player that invests way too
much time into this one game and of
course what you have to show for it well
you know i reach diamond you know
usually usually what you have to show
for it can be summed up in one sentence
yeah
it's like yeah it was fun why is it that
playing like 100 games for 10 hours is
like cena's okay but playing one game
for a thousand hours is like no double
standards right societies
we live in a society that's [ __ ] up we
live in a society
that ain't right
i don't know
i just feel like there are just so many
games nowadays that are available even
if like you have nothing to even even if
you feel like you have nothing to play
or no big releases have come out then
you just go through your [ __ ] steam
library right my steam library is like
my god i have not touched my steam like
i think that's what i think to myself
right i'm like okay so i just finished
this game yeah when i finished 30
incentives for example yeah i was like
all right cool i finished that game
[ __ ] now do i now what do i want to play
normally people will be like oh i have a
[ __ ] like 300 games on my steam that i
haven't even like installed at all nope
instead i go to the playstation store i
download the sona 3 nocturne
[Laughter]
and i was like yeah let's play this
and now i'm now i'm just playing that oh
my god see i i would rather have one
game that i'm really into than a hundred
games that i mildly enjoyed yeah you
know like to to me like like i pokemon
rcs for example it seems like kind of
fun but it doesn't seem like a game that
i could like properly like throw myself
into you know it's it's it's it's weird
for me because i i'd rather be like
fully invested in just like emotionally
invested in
one like a few things why final fantasy
why did that get you emotional because i
heard from every person who [ __ ]
talks about final fantasy that has a
good story
to be fair as much as i heard about like
nfts are great if you just listen to
nftv rules
you know
if you're asking addicts why something's
great it's probably not a good
like did you talk to people who played
it and didn't like it well okay
there's the catch everyone who's played
it has said it's a good game
it's just it's just like for example
like when i played the trial when it
first came out i'll admit it's a great
[ __ ] game
but i i like used a hundred percent of
my brain power to be like you want it's
like i know it's a fun game brain
but you're not going to play it i feel
like if you're only talking to people
who are into it oh they seem to all like
it yeah because they're into it yeah but
that's the thing everyone at least
around me that i know that has or is
playing 14 has said nothing but good
things about it yeah i feel i feel like
there are some people who are like maybe
you know people who are for example
addicted to league or addicted to
overwatch where they're like no just
don't get into it uh it's a it is it is
not a you don't have fun with this game
you're in
you know every game has its life life
graph right yeah yeah final fantasy is
just in it's like it's infancy compared
to league we have like 15 years or no 10
plus years of league of don't do it
don't do it we know
the time has proven us
history has taught us well 14 at this
rate might also get to that point yeah
look look i i don't know if this will be
a poorly aged thing but i'm in for the
story and once i die i do the story i
just i won't really have any other
reasons
they're always coming out with another
expansion it doesn't end
well like you know it like is that is
that microsoft transactions isn't it uh
it's a japanese game of course this
microsoft transaction but like you i
from what i understand you pay for like
any new expansion which is basically
like another part of the storyline so i
mean wow was the same as well right
what you had to you had to pay for
expansions was a subscription site
yeah it was a monthly plus you had to
pay for expansions right yeah and now
you have to pay for points for something
yeah i mean yeah i don't know i don't
know too much about the mmo world um
that's why i play gotcha where i can
choose to put money in
it's
like the cancer cell fighting the aid
cell at this point you know you know
what's better than mmos
gotcha games
everyone's into that lost art aren't
they yeah everyone's into lost i don't
know what it is
i'm too scared to ask i've i've i've
seen a lot of my friends play it on
stream and i'm like okay that looks fun
but
i'm right now i'm into heaven burns red
so i'm explaining that i'm enough for
the story this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn when you use the bathroom you
always close the door behind you right
right
of course of course so why would you let
people look in on you when you go online
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door did you know that your
internet service provider knows every
single website you visit what and what's
worse is that they can sell this
information to add companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
but gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted channel
between your device and the internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices because it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wifi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn themselves and the best part
is using expressvpn is as easy as
closing the bathroom door you just fire
up the app click one button and boom
you're protected so if you're like me
and you believe your online activity is
your business secure yourself today by
going to expressvpn.com trash taste use
my exclusive link e x p r e s s v p n
dot com slash trash taste and you can
get an extra three months for free
that's expressvpn.com
taste back to the episode you know you
know what uh non-toxic game i introduced
these gamers to today
wordle oh yeah
i finally oh my god dude it was like a
weight lifted off my shoulders because
for for months now every time i go onto
twitter like five people on my timeline
are just like tweeting out these like
like these [ __ ] squares it's like
these yellow and green squares i'm just
like is he are this is this like
hieroglyphs or something like what's
what's going on i was like is this like
an invitation to a cult or something
like that do i have to decipher this and
then i joined like the [ __ ]
the
stone smiths or whatever the [ __ ] is
going on
i i was almost more confused once gant
had actually explained it to me because
i was like why are people tweeting this
out i don't know
admittedly it's good it's like a good
like little time waster because there's
only one word a day right yeah yeah yeah
i i think it's like their their
marketing strat i don't know it feels
like on purpose but it was like [ __ ]
five head right because everyone gets
the same word every day and you only get
one words a day right and when you tweet
it out it's kind of like i don't know
it's kind of like tweeting out like a
gold star or something or like an
achievement in a video game right like
but it's the equivalent of being like
yeah so uh yesterday i beat level 127 of
candy crush in like two minutes i mean i
don't know my level i i don't i don't
tweet it out i just do it just to prove
to all the tweets that i see that i can
do it every day yeah i sat there and i
was like but why
why would anyone tweet this out
because like because i guessed a
five-letter word correctly
because i was right
i just couldn't understand it i might am
i missing something
like is it not what about it is an
achievement i'm not attacking anyone who
has tweeted it out you can do it in the
[ __ ]
i just there's some people who were like
they were like i don't know
pretty like big accounts i'm like why
the [ __ ] you tweeting about wordle yeah
i'd like i had like two or three people
i followed that i think we're like
actively
at one point we're like what the [ __ ] is
this world [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know and
then like a week later they're like
got it in two tries baby i was like oh
no
is this final fantasy 14 all over again
no because like the thing i don't
understand about how this trend started
is like
what made people want to tweet
right because who sits there and it's
like yeah i gotta let everyone [ __ ]
get like
you know you think you know when you
like have an app open and you get like
that notification which is like would
you like to review this app and then
post it on your timeline share your
results like who's yeah share your
results who's ever [ __ ] shared the
results before wordle existed and what
what was the black magic the word will
put on their users to make people want
to share the results like when i get
like a high score on temple run i'm not
[ __ ] sharing that because because
it's a [ __ ] mobile share it to your
facebook friends it's like no i don't
think i will yeah everyone who's like yo
facebook sucks like you know twitter is
slowly becoming facebook this is what
boomers do this is what they do yeah
they're like look what i got in
farmville it's like what we're no better
than them
but like what i think it's it's like the
equivalent of like having a newspaper
with like uh like the crossword yeah
yeah right yeah and like your grandpa
comes and shows you oh look at this
completely crossbows are too hard yeah
yeah
way harder yeah
it went from crosswords to like
newspaper sudoku puzzles and then it's
now wordle
because i thought because i was what i
was surprised the most about wordle was
that i thought it was like an app
yeah yeah like all those other ones
right but then i realized it's the
[ __ ] new york times yeah it's just
it's like a thing that the new york
times has yeah which is like i remember
it's joey searching for it on like the
app store it's like no you just you just
type it in the browser and i'm like why
is there like russian apps coming up on
my thing like this
yeah i i remember i tweeted ages ago i
was like i don't know what will it all
is and it's been so long i was too
afraid to ask yeah at least well i mean
you weren't afraid to ask you tweeted
was actually afraid to ask about i don't
even want to i'm keeping this in the
drafts bro i'm [ __ ] trying i mean
like i
like tried my longest to like just not
google it yeah i like refuse to give it
the attention yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is gonna die in a week
and then like i was just like it's going
to it's something that's going to die in
a [ __ ] week or something i don't
[ __ ] know i'll let twitter burn
itself out i didn't even know what it
was called so like i got this close to
like going on the google and being like
uh green and yellow squares on my
twitter timeline
yeah yeah then i gave it a week yeah
didn't die give it two weeks and people
were still posting about it and i'm just
like okay
i need i just i'm just i'm just curious
just curious so okay so how long have
you been doing well now for like for
like a good week or something just just
just every day you just log on when i
remember to when i remember normally
when i see it pop up my timeline i'm
like [ __ ] you that's the reminder [ __ ]
you you look at this man right here
great now now a [ __ ] staff member
damn bigger brain all right take these
guys for helping each other
they got a single letter for free what
he gave me a that's hard yeah he gave me
him
no i give you aim in the right spot come
on
sorry he like didn't help come on
i'm just like these these boys are
cheating this is this is this is an
individual game you know you know you're
not supposed to
you should play uh babble royale have
you seen that game
scrabble battle royale oh yeah i've
heard of it yeah that one that was fun
i just really want i just really miss
playing scrabble
i've never played is that boomer of me
to say i've never played a game of scrap
you've never played scrabble no dude
like you like people keep saying like oh
yeah uno is a friendship ender
monopolist no scrabble is the real
french offender you know you know your
friendship is [ __ ] when you're
fighting with a dictionary in your hand
like that's when you know your
friendship is in the dire strait right
it's like that's that's like oh yeah
we've got a problem here there are a lot
of like three and two letter words that
you're like this is a word yeah yeah
yeah and then when like you know and
then the argument always comes along
with being like well if it's like a
commonly used word that's not in the
dictionary it's not allowed like am i
allowed to use the word yet
because you know why is like a lot of
points it's not in the dictionary though
and then that's when the friendships
just crack
we should do it on stream i think i
think vax and anti-vaxx is in the uh in
the dictionary there's a lot of
brilliant double x yeah likes that it's
a lot of points you can get on youtube
goddamn
everyone's gonna be like scrambling for
those dnxes now man
are we doing a dictionary one or a
non-dictionary run because i thought
dictionaries weren't allowed in scrabble
you say it like it's a speed writer
it's like i think the math thing like a
calculator or no calculator
dictionary that scrabble dictionary run
sorry i'm only a dictionary runner uh i
don't know the strats for non-dictionary
protection
[Laughter]
no we should we should definitely do a
scrabble uh game on uh on after dark
because that
honestly like it's it's it's it's
legitimately fun i'm not just saying
like i'm not being a boomer here like
it's legitimately fun you seem to like
word games though because i remember you
you have countdown was just like yo this
game exists yo how have i never right
it's like yeah like countdown i had a
lot of fun in and you got me into wordle
it's all word games dude
i don't know it's just something fun
about but then again like recently i
have been getting quite boomer yeah i
did see your video which is like am i
getting too old and i remember seeing
that i'm just like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
what are you like commenting
27 he's like i'm dying guys shut the
[ __ ] up
no no i'm like if you're old joey then
what am i see this is how you know these
boys didn't actually watch the video no
i i i
because i recently got back into golf um
and i was like my god that is the most
boomer thing i've ever done see i don't
i don't think golf is a boomer thing you
know i i feel like it's a pretty much i
don't think it's a difference yeah it's
a privileged movie thing so if if you're
broke you can't be playing golf that's
just facts that's true it's just golf
isn't a boomer thing golf is just a uh
you have a lot of displacable incomes
kind of thing i think it's just yeah but
that's the thing right i think people a
lot of people mistake it as a boomer
thing because it's played by a lot of
people of the older generation that's
because they have the time and the money
now yeah and also you know relatively
speaking golf doesn't really take as
much of a physical you know tax on you
as like say you know a rugby or a
cricket right no golf is fun as [ __ ]
yeah i was like actually properly into
golf when i was younger like to the
point where i started getting like
proper golf lessons and everything like
that i went to golf camp a couple of
times golf count
yeah when i was like 10 years old i like
during like summer holidays my golf cam
it's like it's literally just like think
of
you go and like you s you stay over in
like a golf club
uh for like a couple of weeks and every
day you just get up and you just learn
to play golf what yeah and i was i think
like 10 years old and like forget how to
do it no
surprisingly i i kind of remembered it
uh yeah you went to a driving range i
went to a driving range with monkey and
maylene um because there was one like
kind of nearby my house yeah and um it
was a really [ __ ] fancy one like i
knew this was this wasn't like the you
know the downtown alley like you know
[ __ ] we're gonna build this driving
range here because there's nothing else
around kind of thing because like
you you literally got like a buggy
service from the car park to the
building see if you were far away see i
i feel like there's always like levels
of like how into how into you are you
into like golf right because like i've
never obviously i didn't come from those
privileged families like the only golf
clubs i've ever owned were like a pa a
pair of like a
set of golf clubs that i bought in a car
boot itself like 50 bucks yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know so i've i always went to
like you know the really cheap driving
ranges and really cheap they're really
cheap of golf courses but there was
those were still fun as [ __ ] yeah the
ones i went to back in australia were
like still like obviously made in like
you know it's like 70s and like 80s so
it's like it's still very old like
you get like a it's just like this
machine that you just like press a
button and you put a basket under it and
it just like shits out a hundred golf
balls into a basket yeah and then you
kind of like you know one at a time you
put it on the tee and you like whack it
off this one we went to though i don't
know if all japanese driving range is
like this because this is the first time
i went to yeah but like you walk in i'd
never seen like this many polo shirts in
one building
and it's like everyone but like
everyone's like slicked hair like really
like pristine pants and everything like
clearly like i was like oh okay we're in
like a like a nice uh driving range yeah
and they like made us like make these
like membership cards that you didn't
even have to pay for you just like you
just you get you're like okay the moment
you're here you have to make a
membership card and i was like okay
so then you and then you fill this thing
up like a like a credit card you put
like you put cash into it and then you
pay for the golf balls using your
membership card yeah
but and so like because i was so used to
the you know the pressing the button and
then the ball shooting out into a basket
yeah so i was like i was looking for
that machine right i was like okay where
is it it it wasn't there it was
literally just like it looked like a
[ __ ] atm and you'd put the card in
and you were like how many balls would
you like and i was like uh a hundred and
it's like okay go to this you know go to
this field
it's like
where are the balls right i was like
looking around i was like yeah yeah
balls it's like okay whatever i'll just
go to it
there's a [ __ ] you get to it there's
no t on the green
yeah and i'm like there's no t there's
no machine that shits out the balls
i was like okay what do i do and there's
just like a little like you know in like
golfing uh not golfer bowling alleys
right you know there's like the little
tablet that you have yeah
there was just like that but like a tiny
one right so i was like and there's just
one button that just says start okay i
was like okay i press start the [ __ ]
t and the with the ball on top of it
comes out from under the green are you
serious it just goes
what the [ __ ]
and i was like
oh
and i whack it immediately the moment i
whack it the t goes down another ball
appears in its place holy [ __ ] i've been
and i was like this is the most five
head but why the [ __ ] was i wasting my
time i was playing amazing i was playing
golf like a peasant yeah this entire
time being an idiot looking around like
where's the where's the golf ball
shooting machine
i don't know that makes golf sound hella
fun that was so good and then and then
you have like a counter that shows how
many balls you have left and if you say
for example like you know you pay for
100 balls but you know after a while
after you swing a golf club 100 times
your arms and shoulders start to get a
little bit sore yeah yeah so you're like
oh you know maybe i just want to like
call it a day after 80 balls or whatever
so you just press stop the money comes
back into your membership card and then
you can just leave [ __ ] you know that
i'm like
how much is it like to do it it was uh 2
000 yen so about 20 dollars for 120
balls that sounds fun as [ __ ] which is
honestly not bad because like
it's like i remember playing golf as a
kid and it was like i has the image of
being an old man sport but it's like i
still think golf is boring as [ __ ] to
watch right yeah it's one it's one of
those sports where like i cry right now
it's one of those sports where i'm just
like i i like golf i i get golf it's i i
don't understand anyone the only time
i'll ever sit down willingly to watch
golf is when i find a youtube video on
my recommender which is like top 10
miracles during golf tournament okay i
don't think playing golf is boomer i
think watching golf is boomer okay i'm
going to draw the line there i'm going
to draw the line there
um but yeah i mean like i remember i was
like actually like super super into golf
i found it like super fun because i i
wasn't really really the most athletic
kid as a kid i mean like i i was like in
the basketball team but i feel i feel
like i got put into poo into the
basketball team just because i was tall
yeah and that was like the prerequisite
yeah um but i didn't really enjoy so
much um playing like really
high-intensity high-intensity sports
yeah but i just really enjoyed golf
because it was more of like just a
relaxing you just hone one skill yeah
and then there is nothing more
satisfying than that moment where you
just hit the ball perfectly yeah right
and you can tell you hit the ball
perfectly because like sometimes you hit
you hit the ball and it slices or you
know sometimes you sometimes reverse to
the right and then you can just you feel
it in your hands because there's like a
vibration vibration in your hand where
you when you hit it a bit wrong but when
you hit it and you feel like it's like
hitting air you know it's like i'm
hitting nothing at all yeah it's like
it's like hitting nothing at all i've
never played golf you've never oh yeah
only mini golf okay mini golf i feel
mini golf has its own we need to go play
golf yeah we need to go play golf
we should go to the driving range near
my house because like that place was
actually [ __ ] like i want to go back
yeah i i did ask after that session i
looked at marky dead in the eyes and i
was like where do i go to buy a golf
club
i was legit this close to just buying a
golf swing like i remember the one
moment that sold me on golf uh as a kid
because uh
i went to the driving range driving
range is just fun because you just
[ __ ] hit a ball and you just you
don't matter it's just really satisfying
hitting a ball you know i just wanted to
yeah but like on like on like the actual
golf course is where you have to you
have to like actually think about what
you're doing you can't just like blindly
hit a ball and i remember like i was i
had an instructor at the time
and
so like on the driving range and in golf
in general so if you don't know golf
there's like a set of golf clubs and
that is numbered right so the lower the
number the like the less the sharper the
incline is the club right no no it's the
it's less inclined or less inclined yeah
yeah so for example like like a
two iron goes almost straight right so
it's a lot harder to get the ball up and
give it like air time right um so for me
like like my comfort my comfort zone was
like a nice seven iron
because like on the on the driving range
if you want to feel like you can play
golf you get out the seven iron right
because you can get a decent amount of
air with a seven iron like almost
guaranteed it's like a perfect 45
degrees yeah but also like a decent
amount of distance as well so you could
you could feel like yeah i can whack a
[ __ ] ball i can whack a [ __ ] ball
so like so i remember i was on this golf
course uh with this instructor right and
so and so
how i uh and so between me
and the uh the the flag so basically the
hole
um there was like this this this hill
right yeah and uh on the hill was like a
sand trap right so i needed to get i
needed to get enough air to get over the
sand trap and also uh onto like onto the
actual green right i feel like i know
where this is going
no and and so and so
um and so in my mind i'm like this is
two shots this is two shots right
because i need to get over the sound
trap and then another shot to get to the
green so what happens i pull out my
trusty comfort seven iron my my good old
trusty seven iron right and and um i'm
about to hit it and my golf instructor
goes no no
you're not you're not using that seven
nine i've been using the seven iron for
the entire golf course and he picks out
the three iron right yeah and he goes
use this and he goes i go i can't use
that i can't get enough air i'm gonna
hit the sand trap and he goes no you can
do it i believe in you and just like and
i just like what no no i can't do this
this is this is three
this is this isn't even a five iron this
is a three iron he goes no just do it
just trust just trust me just do it yeah
and i remember like it was it was like
it was like you know being like when neo
discovered that he was the one in the
matrix yeah because i remember hitting
this ball
and i couldn't believe that it it just
like so this was the sand trap the ball
went here it went just perfectly enough
over the sand trap and it perfectly
landed on the green right and i was just
like what is this feeling
am i the chosen one what is this and i
know like i like remember that moment
for the rest of my life because like
that was the most satisfying shot i've
ever hit in golf and from that moment on
i was like as even as a kid i was like i
can see why people play golf the only
thing that would have topped that
experience is if your golf instructor in
the wii sports voice was like nice shot
nice approach
so i mean it is a very rewarding sport
uh yeah yeah i mean like all sports are
yeah because so like when i was at the
driving range because it was [ __ ] i
don't know five six years at least
minimum since i last went to a driving
range i think i was in like high school
last time i went so obviously i was like
i knew you know basically like how to
swing and everything but i was [ __ ]
slicing that [ __ ] like crazy every
single time and i'm like
man what why am i slicing it yeah and
just like it got to the point where i
was like deadpan serious just like
slowly like just [ __ ] doing every
single movement possible being way too
serious about this [ __ ] and i was like
and at one point i remember i was like
i got it
i swung
yeah i locked on i was like this is the
position right here i just have to nail
this and the moment i got it i think i
nodded like it was it because again it's
like as god said it's like when you hit
that perfect straight like perfectly
angled shot yeah you just hear the
cleanest like whack sound yeah and
nothing else but when you [ __ ] up you
hear like a hit like it's like a really
like [ __ ] up sound yeah
it's like it's like the best way i can
describe it it's like you know when some
f when you play some fps games and you
get that headshot right and you and like
a lot of a lot of like fps games have
this like really satisfying sound when
you get that hit yeah yeah yeah i think
like golf just has that irl you know
when you get that satisfying like
perfectly like perfect head shot on that
golf ball
it's like designed to have that
satisfying sound i want to go it's just
how do you get into golf it's not like a
thing that well okay so i didn't have a
i don't have a golf set or anything um
monkey and mainly does uh but a lot of
those places like driving range and
stuff like that they give you like
rentals
um so the only ones they gave me was a
seven iron because of course
is that just universal yeah
it's just like the you've never played
just use this we'll start you off with
the seven right so they all they gave me
was a driver and a seven iron right and
they were uh i like happy gilmore
you get into the run-up yeah
that's a good movie yeah
um yeah and then you just like kind of
just get a feel for it after a while but
it's i think it's definitely best to go
with someone who you know knows at least
yeah the bare minimum knows how to swing
a golfer yeah yeah my brother played a
lot of golf company
he played like i think he did like
tournaments and stuff really yeah but i
i never did i was always more into like
stuff that was like way more active
right yeah right running or just
headbutting
[Music]
i mean i mean golf is like monkey mode
but like it's controlled monkey mode
because you're just you just you just
got to whack that doesn't sound very
monkey motive what do you want to try to
describe golf in a way that i like
that's not how it is you're just
whacking a ball i mean how ha that's not
monkey mode no just think of no no
instead of monsters
just think of it instead of an fps where
you shoot someone in the head it's like
an fps but like the bullet is the end of
the golf stick
and the ball is the head that's such a
short
that's all it is you get the perfect
shot boom sorry if you're going to sell
me on golf i i want to try this episode
is sponsored by boxer
do you guys smell that smell what gun or
the smell of fresh spring air is all
around us but god we're inside how can
you smell the fresh spring air well it's
because i've got this awesome sakura
season boxing with me joey how did that
get there it's almost spring and you
know what that means gentlemen it is the
sakura season here in japan and box has
got you lovely sons of petals covered
with sakura themed sweets for this month
do you know what people in japan do joey
what do they do people in japan
celebrate sakura season by gathering
under a tree for hanami which is what's
lava viewing and enjoying picnics
together and luckily gentlemen with this
sakura themed box you can have your very
own hanami at home tell us joey what are
you holding well i'm holding some
kanagawa sakura jelly how beautiful this
thing is
what are you holding this is a sakura
sweet cookie look at this look at that
that's so cute i know did you know that
sacrificing this box whose most
anticipated collection of the year and
if you've been waiting to try them out
oh it's the best time as you can hear
god is having the time of his life so
use our code trash taste 15.
the link in the description now below to
save 15 off your first order go get
yourself a piece of japan's freshest
season with the monthly boxer i'll have
what he's having
have you guys ever been to any of the uh
batting cages before yeah yeah i [ __ ]
love it a lot harder than it looks it is
a lot harder it's also a lot scarier
than it looks yeah because even when you
put it on like the slowest mode i think
a lot of machines throw at like 80
kilometers an hour and that's slow yeah
and you're like oh yeah that doesn't
sound too
fast or anything but then you remember
that's like the speed that cars travel
on some highways and you're like oh
that's
that's pretty fast i gotta hit a car
with a baseball bat
[Music]
i can't hit a ball at what cost
my arms are probably fall off yeah yeah
yeah those those things are [ __ ] hard
i remember trying to do the hundred and
twenty yeah out of like 20 shots i
managed to hit one yeah that wasn't very
good it was i was just guessing it's
getting used to the speed it's got a lot
harder learning curve than when you play
in every [ __ ] mini game on like any
any rpg yeah because like in like you
play on like persona 5 whatever you you
missed the first two shots persona yeah
yeah yeah there's you can go to bangkok
of course of course you can do homework
in persona why why couldn't you like do
like go to batting cages but that's how
you up your charisma dude yeah
yeah
how does it up your charisma because the
more shots you get the more charismatic
you're so likable
yeah but i remember like you played on
persona any mini game or [ __ ]
probably yakuza or something yeah of
course yeah i think you missed like the
first two balls and you're like okay i
got a feel for this yeah you started
getting them in real life you missed
like the first ten and you're like i
don't even i i can't even keep up with
this like my eyes still in real life
it's not even like you don't you can't
even attempt to swing after the first
view like the first few is like seeing
how fast the ball actually goes and by
the time you realize that it's behind
you like oh
okay i'm going to be here for a while
and then maybe around like swing seven
or eight you're like i think i have the
courage to start slinging i just never
swing fast enough yeah my eyes were just
way faster than my arms yeah
that's what i learned
i mean i'm british so we don't play
baseball yeah no it's not a thing i mean
yeah i mean you know australia doesn't
play baseball why though so like holding
a baseball bat was just weird and trying
to hit a baseball yeah but we played
cricket we i i didn't play well the
welsh and the british i i did not play
any i've never played did you play
cricket i played in the infield one time
i had to catch it but i never got to bat
but like everyone bats though
no but like because we were when we were
in school we only had like an hour right
so we didn't we never played it that
often right did you never play in like
pe or whatever i did but i i was always
in the infield i don't know why
but like this team swap over yeah i know
but we never had time to run out of time
sorry
we never played it often because you
know you have to do like every sport
yeah yeah so we didn't we only cricket
often i was never good at the team games
that's what i learned i'm really bad at
team games and we never did golf because
that's like how you're gonna get kids to
play golf yeah it's not i mean golf
wasn't like was never a pe thing it was
more of just like after yeah like a
extracurricular thing yeah yeah but we
did like
um i don't know we did like everything
what was your favorite sport during pu
i always liked athletics when we did
that like running long jump high jump
stuff like that yeah yeah javelin
jeffrey that's really fun shot put was
fun that's cause i was like a [ __ ]
animal you seem like a short form
you seem like a shot kind of guy
that doesn't surprise you why doesn't
as much as i've tried my god damn
hardest i can't like i cannot run long
distances right no matter how much i
practice i'm sure there's some god tier
runner in the comments being like you
just gotta power through me i gotta hit
that wall you gotta keep going never
stop get that pump off you gotta breathe
through your nose
you know like i
i am a sprinter that's what i always was
right and like whenever i
no matter how many times i trained i
just was [ __ ] doing long distance um but
i i wanted my to show goddamn bad
yeah so i ended up just doing sprinting
and like like because i told me it's
like sprinting and like throwing and
long jump is all kind of explosive yeah
yeah
for me yeah for me high jump and long
jump was like the ones i excelled
yeah long jump long jump for me was the
best one that i was that that i was in
athletics as well i was just really good
at jumping i don't know
yeah yeah yeah did you uh like my
school's really small yeah i've said
this a bunch so like i was the only one
who went to athletics after school like
because we had
we had a local track that had been
founded by the lottery right so right
next to where i live there was amazing
facilities like amazing track nothing
like this anywhere else near me like
because this is just like unheard of
yeah it was like an actual good track
yeah so i used to go there and i was the
only person in my like year who who did
this so i was the only one who knew how
to throw like a javelin you need to
throw a shot putt knew how to do the
long jump like the correct way to do
discus and stuff like that i didn't do
this so so um we were doing it and uh
every year we had the sports day right
did you have to do the track and field
yeah
yeah
yeah and you had like houses yeah
gryffindor and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i
think i was in like
i was in like the house called scissors
this is scissors this is scissors there
wasn't rock or paper
so it was like sizzling or something
yeah and um
did you have how did you decide who does
the events how did you decide this uh
basically it was just like picked yeah
it was like would you like to go to this
there was someone who was obviously the
best at an event they would be like well
you're you're oh no for us it was just
like you just put your hand up it's like
who wants to do the 100 meter sprint and
then everyone who wants dual puts their
hands up and then if you didn't want to
do it you didn't so if there's too many
people how did they decide oh everyone
did it oh there was no limit yeah well i
mean to be fair my score as well was
also very very small like we only had
like you know 500 people in our school
how many people were in your grade or
year like
60. okay so yeah it's not same for me
yeah and so they there was like only
two or three people were allowed to do
each event right and
for the first few years when i did it
there was no limit on how many you could
do
and so i was just like i'll just i'll
just do like everything yeah because i
liked i loved sprinting i loved racing
as well yeah so i would be like yeah
i'll do the 100 200 400 long jump the
triple jump javelin shot putt it was fun
it was good because there was some
people on my because we had like groups
of like 15 of us yeah yeah split and
there was like half of them that like i
don't want to do anything yeah yeah i
was like oh great well there always was
here
for me you had like a maximum of four
but like everyone did like four or
something right see so then
there was one year where like i did the
hundred two hundred and i'd won all of
the events bought one
and so i was like oh this is fun i won
like six out of seven events and like
and then the next year they were like no
no you can't do you want to watch that
you can do three now and i was like
they just nerfed you i was like why are
you using me huh that's not fair but
this is this is the thing right is that
i'm sure if i went to any other school
where people like knew how to do like a
thorough javelin correctly yeah or like
jump correctly because like this is when
like long jump everyone was still doing
the jump where you like just jump yeah
yeah another one where you jump into a
sit yeah yeah yeah so it was really easy
to like
do better yeah obviously yeah once
you've yeah i mean same with like uh
high jump as well right if you knew how
to do it yeah everyone just like did did
like the you know the standing scissor
kick the white way but like i was doing
the full like [ __ ] arch back yeah
yeah yeah torpedo jump right and then
you're like oh my god this guy's a god
the other kids can't compete if you're
like actually doing like professional
technique exactly i'm like oh yeah of
course you're only going to be able to
jump like a medium you're [ __ ] doing
this like
the scissor kick
yeah of course i couldn't do that though
i was terrible i i i was really fun
though i i really liked it yeah i mean
when you're winning of course you like
it yeah yeah yeah i thought that would
make me popular didn't they yeah yeah
well like during elementary i was like
dominating long jump in height
yeah i did turns
definitely did not make me popular if
anything it just gave the people more
right to be like oh your name's joey and
you're good at jumping things
just like a baby kangaroo i never
[ __ ] heard the end of that i
i'm christ
i just felt like i just saw your soul
just leave your eyes like like years of
like torment just came rushing back
uh one time
very very tense moment yeah i just i
just won 100 meters and immediately
after they were like let's do the 200
meters they didn't think let's space it
out
right i was actually naked yeah and i
was lining up for the 200 meters and i
really really really wanted to win i
wanted this more than like any i don't
know why i was so ultra competitive this
is like the olympics for me yeah i need
this
i was so goddamn nervous that like i was
like what is this i felt like a little
drizzle go down my leg
right
i was so nervous that like i for like a
brief moment repeat myself like 0.1
seconds and i was like stop it's like a
little bit yeah it was like a little
beep and i was like
that's never happened before what was
that
[ __ ]
luckily i but you know i didn't i didn't
give a [ __ ] that i beat myself but my
party was like no one else saw that
right
but luckily i would i was so sweaty from
the previous event still that nobody had
thought that i pissed you just like
shake it off
just shake your leg
just like let's get back to it boys
i i went to it and then yeah i won but i
really needed the piss after it
my bladder it was have you ever been
that nervous your bladder just
completely opened no yeah i've i've had
that before brother that happened
trust me i've never been i didn't know
that could happen yeah i've i've done a
little like before oh my god yeah
i had that i had that during i had that
before like a really important like
piano competition
and uh yeah
but but at least but like the the
problem was i had it a lot worse than
you probably were like because i was
wearing a suit no oh no i was wearing
shorts yeah
it came out and you were already sweaty
right yeah yeah i was like in a
well-air-conditioned room with like long
pants like in a suit
with like all these like really properly
dressed like asian kids next to me i'm
just like
oh [ __ ]
did you see it could you see the pair
luckily not but my god it was it was
hard to use the pedal while my leg was
also a little bit wet
i was like oh god i don't know how did
the stream get down to go all the way uh
like almost to my knee oh my god that's
yeah
they missed this [ __ ] scene in your
life in your line in april
when they're [ __ ] waiting
i love the chapter where corset pierces
himself
when you're a kid
you get anxious exactly i i also used to
try it i felt really bad for the kid who
had to follow after oh
because i'm like i didn't i didn't check
but i was like i'm sorry if the seat is
a little there's a wet pad there's a
weird patch on that seat right there
that shoot god i [ __ ] nailed the
competition though so worth it in the
end but
did you win the 200 meters i did i did
and i was also
so competitive
uh to the point where i don't know if i
can do this now but when i was a kid
when i was running and i thought like oh
i really need to stop
i just wouldn't stop and i would always
end up throwing up when i stopped when i
saw you you were that you're the kid who
just threw up everywhere or always
because right to me it was like i was
like no i i need to win like i have to
win
so like if there was a like like i'm at
the last stretch yeah i still got a
little left in me and i'm like i can't
stop now i need to throw up so
so one one year um this is again so i i
was doing like six events
and i've won the hundred i'd won the 200
and again right after it what comes
after the 200 it's the 400 yeah because
it's kind of like the same thing yeah
you sprint at the end you kind of run
fast at the same time why would they not
split it up like they were it was it was
just because because in our school they
split it off yeah i think i think they
might have assumed that different people
would be doing
assumed people would do different things
yeah i would give max like two minutes
break yeah so i was doing the 400 right
and i was already like before i even
started this race i remember i was like
like because i was already still naked
from the other one and i was like how
the [ __ ] am i gonna win this one yeah
and so i'm i'm in this race right i
might i get to the 200 meter mark right
this is where you're like the on switch
has to come on yeah start sprinting yeah
because like i'm i'm like kind of like
i'm in the middle i'm not really in i'm
kind of i got a lot of ground to make up
because i was going a little too slow
yeah so i just start going crazy man i
get like to 50 meters and i'm like oh no
on the side on the side of the racetrack
right luckily it's a grass racetrack so
yeah that's just extra compost yeah and
i luckily i was not i was not in the
middle
oh it was i was on the i was in the
first lane so i just i'm like 50 meters
into this sprint i'm going all out and i
just have to i just
i was literally just like powering
through like a machine and then just had
to just start vomiting it was awful my
god because i just didn't know my limits
as a kid i just didn't i just didn't
like yeah my willpower was just beyond
my body's ability apparently but it
happened all the time during long
distances while i always threw up
well like i i sucked at long distance i
think mostly most mostly because i have
asthma so i could only do like 200
meters at most before like my asthma
would like start to kick in yeah yeah
yeah it was rough man long distance is
horrible yeah yeah it is because it was
really muddy and freezing it was always
during winter did you do yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you got to be a real masochist
to enjoy long run like long running like
it's like why would you especially
people who do it for like club
activities and stuff it's like what do
you do after school i lo i run yeah yeah
why
because so did they make all the kids do
it when you did it yeah no no so like if
kids so basically kids could opt in and
out at our school oh you were knocked
out yeah
every kid needed to do an activity yeah
you know they you know you didn't have
to do like a certain like you know a
certain amount but you need to do at
least one oh no no no there were some
years where i was just like i don't want
to do anything today dude for my school
it was like on this day we're doing
we're doing two kilometers you have to
do the two kilometers oh [ __ ] that you
have no choice we had we had other
events for that kind of stuff where like
kids have are you talking about pe or
sports day p okay no if it's pe then
yeah if we're doing activities
yeah sorry yeah yeah if if it's pe even
if it's pv
uh you have to do the actually yeah
because i remember that like they would
like get really angry at the kids that
were just like walking
distance like shout at them and be like
the [ __ ] you doing
what's this like [ __ ] army yeah
like the sas or whatever
how many likes so because like we had at
our school we had like i think like four
different sports days or like four days
yeah yeah
so we we had the we had the traffic
winter olympics in australia no so we
had like a track and field day yeah
right and then we also had like a what
we call the swimming carnival which was
we went to like our local swimming pool
and we would do like swimming like
events yeah we we got we got one sports
day in the year and it was like every
kid every kid looked forward to it
because it was just basically a day off
from school where you just do fun stuff
and then yeah you can sit on the grass
and give a [ __ ] and then we got it yeah
and then we had another sports day uh
where we did it on the beach
so we did like you know like beach flags
and like uh you know like you'd like
races like thousand meter races on the
beach and stuff like that like surfing
events and stuff like that and that was
just like another day where like if kids
didn't want to do it the kids didn't
have to do it and then we had a fourth
one during the winter and this was the
worst one it was called they don't have
it anymore but uh it was called the
walkathon
and walker yeah so it's think of like a
marathon right which is like 42 point
something kilometers yeah it's that but
you can walk it if you want so basically
it was it was basically we start from
the school you'd walk 20 kilometers
across like seven or eight beaches
because that was like the area we lived
in and then you turn around and you walk
all the way back to the school what and
you had to do that during the day what
and uh and i think they got rid of it
because
some
because i think some of like the higher
grade kids were just like calling ubers
yeah [ __ ] that yeah because like you
because like when you when you reach
like the halfway point you get like a
sticker like put on your like wrist so
yeah that's how you know when you came
back to the school that you made it to
the halfway point so it's like that was
their like foolproof way of making sure
you did the whole thing speed runners be
like i found it yeah i found a clip yeah
it's like i come on a club
so what the senior kids would do is that
like they'd walk away from you know they
do maybe like the first kilometer yeah
they'd like walk into a street call an
uber
get them to drive to like a kilometer
away from the halfway point and they
just like come out being like oh hey i
made it
and then they do it again
and uh but but i think they got rid of
it because uh like kids were cheating
but it was also like a charity event for
the school right so like you had to like
you know you had to pay like i think it
was like a dollar per student or
whatever for like pay to walk 42. pay to
walk 42 kilometers i mean for some kids
it was like oh [ __ ] yeah we just have to
walk today don't have to do class hell
yeah i'll take that did you ever get uh
told off in school for stuff you did
outside of school
uh uh like as in like in the school
grounds or outside outside of school
like what so
like
the area where i went to school was like
really small yeah and like i was
i was like i don't know how old i was
like 13 14. yeah i was like there was
like a bunch of like ruined castles
where i grew up
and one time i was like climbing the
wall of this castle yeah and what a
teacher happened to be walking in that
park
right and she just saw me she didn't say
anything but i was just climbing it i
wasn't having a great time probably
wasn't the safest thing yeah um it was
quite high up and then i came into
school the next monday because it wasn't
like a weekend i got bollocked by the
[ __ ] teachers they told me off and i
was like i was so confused i was like
this doesn't
it's allowed it was outside of school
what and they were telling me off for
climbing this wall outside of school not
even anywhere near school
i don't think i was like
yeah i don't think we had anything like
that because like because because the
the town that i grew up in was like it
was it was small but it was also quite
wide yeah so like uh yeah i don't think
i ever saw my teachers outside of school
yeah i mean i i was in like hove in
brighton so you know i mean that's
that's like a city so yeah i don't think
people cared about did you guys have
like did your schools have any rivalries
with like
other schools we were attached to
another school yeah we had like a sister
school as well so like i was the school
i went to was the boys school and then
like at the bottom of the hill there was
the the girls school
we like physically our schools were
physically attacked oh no
but there were different schools yeah so
you could walk into the other school
from school that just sounds like a bad
time
i was like that just sounds like some
fights yeah were there a lot of fights
that happened yeah it was like the
corridor like where like the walls were
like different colors like there's a
weird line
right so that's where like if [ __ ] went
down it was always like at this like it
was like the the dmz in like north korea
it was like
oh my god standing on the board
it was like [ __ ] went down so the reason
why this this weird like it sounds
really bizarre right yeah yeah so we
were a while speaking school and we were
really small and when we were attached
she was a massive english speaking
really [ __ ] big english speaking yeah
because our school was too small and
like poor to have our own like sports
facilities right so that that school
also had this massive uh sports like
kind of complex attached to it swimming
pool
tennis like massive sports halls astro
turf massive fields tennis courts
everything right yeah we had everything
like rugby pitches
literally everything um and so our
school would basically share the
facilities with them right so whenever
we needed to go to use the
pool or anything we always walked
through this school right yeah went
there so we could walk through their
school but they couldn't walk through
our school
because our schools are on the edge why
would the like i'm just imagining like
the architect of that building just
being yeah this is gonna be hilarious
it's weird yeah it's good because like
they just wanted to make a fight
because of course kids are gonna [ __ ]
fight each other and there was like
there was like there was like uh there
was that corridor and there was two
outside gates that also connected that
were pretty big so whenever it was like
snow or anything as well that would turn
into like the fighting zone yeah i just
remember the story of like going back to
the the teachers getting angry outside
of the school grounds did you guys ever
used to do like pe activities outside of
school yeah of course you'd go to them
so like one of the ones that we did uh
quite often was because because our
school was right next to a beach we did
a lot of like ocean kayaking
uh which was like really fun right like
you just like through two or three boys
at a time get on the side yeah oh yeah
it was very dangerous um but damn kayak
he got a guy can't go
i gotta go kayaking you guys got to go
kayaking yeah what the [ __ ] what sailing
yeah we had sailing i learned how to
sail i'm sorry i'm so jealous
though i remember there was one story
for that there
it's such a bad story but uh there was
like because we were on manly beach and
on one of the things and one of the
beaches uh because it's like a bay
basically so it's surrounded by these
cliffs and there's a lot of like really
like pristine like penthouses that are
like kind of overlooking the bay if you
like kind of look up at the cliffs uh
there's this one time
where some we were just kayaking along
the bay
and then one of the boys was like oi
check it out
i'm like what we look up and there's
just like a chick standing like in a
bikini just like looking down at us
right
and uh you know she was a very
attractive lady
and we were you know we were like in
11th grade so we were like 17.
eating stuff like that yeah so basically
what about the commitment so one of the
kids was like
sorry i know what he's gonna say so one
of the boys just starts going
tits out for the boys to itself all the
boys
tits out for the boys and that sounds
like the most australian [ __ ] yeah
and then a couple and then couple of the
other boys start joining along
and then before you know it
it's like there's like 15 kayaks like 30
boys in this bank just all going kids
out for the boys to itself all the boys
the thunder joke
it was like a scene out of mad max
it was [ __ ] crazy and then of course
the girl
flashes everyone goes yeah
oh my god and the teacher and of course
and of course the teacher we had that
day was a female teacher she was like
what the [ __ ] are you boys doing
and we just like and we just bolt in our
kayaks just like get away from the
seizure we got absolutely rinsed
the most teenage australian boys story
ever only boys
[Music]
oh
[Music]
they didn't let you do anything like
that no i mean like i i i wouldn't trust
a kid out in the sea i don't i'm
surprised i'm surprised
we got to go to um
lit areas in wales that were like kind
of like camps for like three four days
and um they were basically like they
would be like listen boys we gotta we
could do kayaking or you can do sailing
problem is you only got six sailboats
and we've got we've got that everyone
else can do kayaking like 30 kids i was
like well [ __ ] i want to even though i
didn't really
like sailing i didn't know anything
about it i was like well that's the one
that has less i want to do that yeah so
i put my hand up to do it and somehow i
got chosen to do it i did sailing i
[ __ ] loved it it was amazing but they
gave us those like um you know boat
plastic like really cheap boat plastic
the one where they knock it and it
sounds hollow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's really coarse as well like it's
basically like a
a boat that was a shell of plastic with
a with a like uh what's it called as a
hull uh
what's the thing that goes through the
bottom
another rudder uh
sale
it goes in the bottom i have no idea i
don't remember
so you just have this slab of plastic
you put in to allow you to say all this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we
learned how to sail and it was great and
uh yeah it was really good because like
talking about the math the mess no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no i've never selled before in my
life
this is at the front and then it was one
where you turn it and then in the bottom
underneath the water you slide in a
thing
not the rudder
sorry i'm not i don't know it's a
sailboat so you you you didn't do the
direction with the the you did the
direction with the sail not that like
you'd pull on the sails
right yeah
you lean it's like sorry it was really
cool because like you'd be doing that
badass [ __ ] like you'd be leaning yeah
half the boat would be out the water
yeah yeah yeah
dude he was so [ __ ] like horizontal
maybe i don't know either way so and
then you would like you'd be taught like
okay let's say you flip your boat here's
how you jump out the boat jump on the
piece of plastic outside the boat push
it down jump back in the boat and get it
back yeah so [ __ ] cool i loved it so
much i got really good at it and then
the head guy was like you know what
every every every year or so there's a
kid who gets really good at sailing and
i let him try the the real boat and i'm
like oh [ __ ] really and then so he like
out of this like really gross looking
shed in the water it was one of those
sheds that was like
there's no floor yeah it's just for the
boat yeah yeah yeah he pulls out this
massive catamaran massive yeah bear in
mind i've been in this like one-person
boat this thing could easily fit like
four six people on it right he's like go
take it out for a spin
and i'm like i'm like i'm like
this looks [ __ ] scary what do you say
like the rich uncle joins a ferrari
let's see if you can handle this one
right
so i started taking this thing out it's
going well i'm managing it it's a lot
harder you have to run you have to like
get across way more a lot more really
full body because you've got to really
like get under put your put your body
away you've got to like throw yourself
around on this thing to steer it it's
going well it's going well suddenly we
get a big gust of wind and i'm trying my
goddamn best to save this i'm trying my
best i get to the side i'm trying to
like i'm trying to unleash the mess so
that we can get some like we can get the
boat back down right unfortunately the
boat just keeps going it keeps going and
then it does it it gets sideways
from this point now this boat is too
heavy unlike the other boat right my
body weight could shift it back my body
weight can't do [ __ ] yeah and it is
literally like the sinking boat like
titanic it is just like i'm sitting on
the top of the boat like at the top
just slowly going down down
until he gets about the halfway point
where it won't sink anymore right
so i'm just sitting there and then he he
comes over disappointingly in like the
speedboat and he's like i see
he's like he's like well he's like you
want the choke
see he's like well at least help me tie
this tie the rope around this part and
i'll turn it back over and then he got
on the boat and he was like i'll show
you how to drive it and i was like
i let him down i let him down he sailed
it back and then i was like a
disappointment and i was never allowed
to try it again there was a [ __ ] i
felt like that was a look in hindsight i
was like that was ridiculous i feel like
that was a big step it's a big jump
alone as well with the camera and you
can normally have like two people on it
yeah yeah it's the big one with the big
net you know yeah yeah yeah it's
ridiculous it wasn't like a full-sized
massive one it was like a smaller
version but still it was like i'm so
jealous i never got to do that in my
school and we we live on a [ __ ] we
live in brighton you live in brighton
yeah yeah white white like
it was in a lake and a river so it's a
lot easier it was a really big lake
don't you wouldn't want to do that in
the ocean
that's dangerous you get swept [ __ ]
away
in this lake you just get happy for me
that's about it
no biggie yeah i mean i don't think
there was any like big lakes near us so
we didn't really do any water sports i
think the most we did was just we had
like a we had like a swimming pool a
local swimming pool do you mean there's
lakes everywhere
i know i mean we would not like how far
did you drive to get to this lake uh two
three hours
you drive two three hours just for this
that's like the entirety of wales that's
like that's like a
that's like a [ __ ] school trip for us
it was it was yeah it was like it was a
three-day weekend school trip oh you
made it sound like it was one afternoon
yeah you made it sound like oh yeah we
this is for this one lesson
because like the kayaking thing for us
was just like down there oh no no no
this is like it's like so there's like
areas in the i'm pretty sure it's funded
by the welsh government
like basically every welsh school gets
like a weekend there right so everyone
gets to have turns so these like they're
like really [ __ ] up that makes more
sense so yeah there's like uh you know
it's it's kind of like a thing you go
it's like hey try a bunch of different
sports try kayaking try uh canoeing try
sailing wall climbing
everything just everything see what you
like and so it was really fun i'm glad i
got to do it i wish i kept up with
sailing but unfortunately
sailing is a a very luxury sport to be
able to do yeah yeah so not like oh yeah
you can just go sailing yeah yeah
unfortunately it sucks really because i
feel like there's so many sports out
there that i could have fell in love
with
but the financial stability of like i
guess that's absolutely economical
that was like every sport ever for
everyone right i mean that's like that
was like me and skiing and snowboarding
that's why i never was able to get into
it because uh my family unfortunately
could never afford to go on a skiing or
snowboarding trip it's either not enough
money not enough space or both yeah well
i'd love to i've been skiing and
snowboarding like the majority of my
life and i would love to earn a
snowboard or skis but it's an absolute
nightmare to deal with transporting it
yeah and taking it everywhere and i also
it's really expensive it is expensive
yeah i know that you can ship it from
hotel to like god you sound like you had
such like fun school trips like you went
to like america for a school trip yeah
like yeah that's [ __ ] crazy to me
well that was that was insane that was
like the first year they did that yeah
that was really expensive as well i
remember i had to like beg my parents
and they were like
because our score wasn't that rich like
i think i think the richest thing that
our school did for the rugby team
because we like excelled in sports at
our school was like the senior rugby
team was allowed to go to like play uh
rugby in europe for like oh wow wow yeah
but like that was only like the select
like maybe like you know top 20 people
who were like good at rugby i can't even
remember what we did for our school
trips
the rest of the time we just went to
like the local water silo yeah you know
something boring i don't know if this is
just because like it's a really small
place but i imagine that when you're in
a city it probably feels like less
inclined to get you out of the city
whereas when you're in the countryside
there's nothing right so i feel like
they had way more
pressure to try and get you to do
something right especially because you
know in at least sport uh in wales like
sports is like a massive deal it's a
very important part of like the culture
and doing sports is seen as a very very
like you have to do it not doesn't
matter what you do just do sports like
yeah yeah you got to do so you know
there's a really big incentive for them
to make us go and do sports and go on
sports trips and do all this stuff
furthest we ever went in a school trip
or anything was like during like school
camps yeah but that we did every year
but and that was like maybe like you
know four or five hours away which in
the grandest scheme of australia is not
far at all
but like yeah i don't i don't remember
like going on like school excursions
going further than like an hour away
yeah i mean i think the furthest i've
ever went for a school trip was like
france it's because every school trip
goes to france for like
you're in brighton yeah yeah exactly you
get at least [ __ ] you [ __ ]
europeans got to go to other countries
that was not enough for us
other countries are like don't exist
it's like oh what's the closest country
uh papua new guinea how far away is that
uh like a three-hour plane ride it's
like you're overall your own country is
like far away from your country
we didn't even get to go to the other
states
like no that's too far god god forbid
we're going to be on a plane for an hour
and a half no of course not you probably
had better school facilities though than
we had we got to go on a trip and they
were like you just forget about the fact
they have to share a chair
no i mean even then it was like you know
like school like school camp for example
it was like yeah i guess you know
everyone got their own seat on the bus
or whatever but like that was the most
we got
[Music]
what
privileged okay what were your
i i didn't get school meals but like
were your were your school meals good
what did you get
at school meals there's no cafeteria
there was a cafe like what did they
serve at the cafeteria uh the most like
luxury thing ever was uh this was
[ __ ] it was just a chicken two
chicken tenders in a in a broad role
that was literally that was that [ __ ]
cost four dollars fifty dollars yeah to
me you knew the kids who were eating
goods or who were the kids that could
afford a ham and cheese panini like if
it was cheese paneer yeah yeah you got a
[ __ ] panini dude bro they gave you
more than they just called it bread
that was all we everything everything
was bread for us it was literally just
two [ __ ] microwave chicken tenders in
a hot dog roll and then if you wanted
ketchup or mayonnaise it was available
for you for like 20 cents
oh my god but even then it was like
because so like i never bought anything
at the at our cafeteria just because i
was like i'm not [ __ ]
way too expensive
for a chicken tenderloin that's our deal
yeah this is where
uh child connor really learned inflation
because this is where it really came to
hit me yeah because i remember i used to
have this i was always given the same
amount of money from like the young age
to spend at the cafeteria and i remember
like when i started high school i could
get any of the meals yeah they weren't
amazing meals by the end i literally
couldn't buy any of the meals unless i
like had half a meal the day before and
then saved and then and then yeah like i
think how did you not renegotiate with
your parents
like
like mom dad their mindset was like well
your brother managed completely fine
throughout high school with this much so
why what are your well yeah because i
think in my household like i i got
allowance for doing chores like pokemon
right and you know it was like maybe
like you know 20 bucks max per month
right which you know to a 10 year old is
is a lot of money yeah but at the same
time
you know when your school
at age 10 gave you [ __ ] meat pies for
like a dollar fifty you know and like
you know those like [ __ ] squeezy
ketchup packets yeah those were 20 cents
and i was like dog i'm not paying 20
cents i'm not paying a literal 100th of
my monthly allowance for a little
[ __ ] squirt of ketchup like i'm not
[ __ ] doing that you guys didn't have
packed lunches like
i had to have packed lunches for most of
the days yeah so yeah so like most of my
days for me as well was like pack
lunches right because my my mom was like
not my father i'm not giving you [ __ ]
money yeah you're all that expensive
because for me like my allowance would
like last the entire week and then i'd
treat myself to the ham and cheese
panini that was that was that was like
the friday meal that i was like
that you did it the smart way i i was
like you know what i could buy that
chicken tenderloin but i could also buy
this yu-gi-oh booster pack as well okay
okay okay i was gonna say here's what i
did
i would uh i'd get so i get two pounds a
day right which was like i could buy one
meal if i waited like a day and like i
had something small yeah um and so i was
like but i actually want
video games instead so i would go into
the town which is like a 20 minute walk
i would go to the it's called home
bargains yeah in the uk it's like a
poundland or whatever yeah i would buy a
family bag of crisps
like 12 packs for a pound yeah and i
would just eat that the whole week
this is awful this is probably why it's
the most british thing i've ever heard
you were rationing on chips yeah you you
were just on a crisp diet
as a kid yeah
i was like because because right a video
game back then it was 30 pounds yeah
right right so if i if i did this for a
whole month i got a new game yeah sure
my mom was wondering where the [ __ ] i
got this game from
she didn't even know that i was getting
i was eating chris it's probably an
awful thing to do with my body but i
didn't care i was like 15. i wanted the
video game you see you had so much more
of a stronger willpower than me because
like i could not save money for that
long i could i did if i could i had the
i had the object in mind i was like i
want the new halo game i'm not even no
dude in my head i was like every time i
went to like an electronic store and i
was like oh the new the new mario party
on we is out how much does it cost
eighty dollars oh
i'm like okay i could save up four
months worth of allowance together but
my birthday is also in seven months time
so uh maybe i could just like hint at it
now and then just wait seven months for
me to actually get the game which is
what i did yeah because for me like when
i wanted to buy a video game like i grew
up in like like when i was in school i
was it was like the n64 snares era yeah
and like games back then was like 60
pounds a game yeah yeah yeah yeah um for
like a cartridge yet was it really yeah
yeah it was just like half
like half yeah like i i remember when
like when like games started coming out
on disks i'm just like why is it so so
much cheaper now what the hell and the
graphics are better this is what what
kind of hacks are they probably
listening to is like mesh producing
those things yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense
yeah so like back back in those days
like there was no [ __ ] work and
afford like a cartridge game like the
only times i was getting new games was
like christmas and birthday those were
the two times of the year where i got
games and like i was praying that i
could like i was praying that my parents
bought like the right games every time
yeah i was like mother i awaited an
entire year
if i don't get at least three games i am
going to rage
when i turned like 16 they were like we
want you to have a bit of an allowance
so that you can learn how to manage your
money and i was like oh thanks and i was
just thinking like i've got a lot saved
already though
i was like this is just adding to the
wealth this is how i become basis i
think i think my parents thought the
same way but only after they found out
that i got rejected from my mcdonald's
job so they were like there's no saving
you you will love your allowance so you
don't end up being a bomb the more i
think about it more i was like yeah i
don't know if i was always going to be
that kind of way with money i don't know
i wonder is it like i do i guess you
have to teach your kid how to learn how
to uh manage money yeah that's when i
see videos but like nobody taught me how
to manage money i just spent a little
while when i was like 20 and stuff and
i'm like oh you have to do this
i just think you got a little shark
a very very very british thing what
christmas reckon i was eating by the way
walkers no
that's too expensive quavers no think
think cheap
[ __ ] what's a cheap don't look at me man
this is for very british audiences right
now i i don't know it's gonna hit you
like a wave this goes oh my [ __ ] god
okay okay i completely forgot that they
even existed i haven't had disco since
like
you're like 12. yeah i was like how did
what did i reach double digits when the
last time i had disco i can't [ __ ]
remember like the cheap [ __ ] chips yeah
they were like
weirdly good but there was probably so
much like msg and [ __ ] yeah oh they were
really tasty but they were weirdly like
super cheap like compared to all the
other chips but they taste really
[ __ ] good really good
chris review this episode is sponsored
by book walker what's up my beautiful
book loving brethren we're trash test
and we're here to introduce to you
book walker what's that oh you know just
one of the most popular ebook stores for
english manga and light novels out there
on their up you can read official ebooks
directly from the publishers themselves
meaning you don't only just get the
newest releases from manga and light
novels but by doing so you also support
the original authors as well oh my god
and if you're new to the platform you
should check out their limited time deal
where you can get up to 50 coinback on
the total amount from your initial
purchase wait that's a huge bargain you
mean i can buy all 34 volumes of attack
on titan and then i get back 17 volume
worth of coins to spend on other ebooks
that can't be right no way no way you
are exactly right what and if that
doesn't sound enticing enough for new
users you can use our coupon code trash
taste at checkout you can save five
dollars on your first purchase so what
are you waiting for sign up to
bookwalker for free today and enjoy some
of their generous discount promotions
coinback campaigns and digital bonus
items for free today so check out their
service by clicking that link in the
description down below thank you to
bookwalker and back to the episode i've
always had like because
i don't know if it was just my school in
australia but like you know when you
watched like american uh like high
school movies yeah and that had like the
cafeteria
well that was like the lunch lady and
they were yeah this was like the serving
of the day you know kind of [ __ ] like i
don't know why did you look at that and
go like i wish i had that in my school
well i think americans wish they had
that in there yeah yeah i mean like
because i remember like watching
american high school movies and i'm like
damn i wish my high school was cool like
every simpsons episode
i watched and like bob was in the
cafeteria i was like man that looks
[ __ ] cool what does every american
school have that lo and behold i know
not every american school has that yeah
i was just shocked that everyone had
cars
that's what blew me away
yeah there's like it's like a 15 year
old kid yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like
yeah i'll pick you up tonight i was like
it was like do you mean your parents are
going to pick you up today at all i
don't know what was going on in the
2000s but like every single thing it
wasn't about like if you had a car it
was like which car you had yeah yeah
yeah i was like what are you
you all have cars it's like it's like
yeah it's like oh sorry i'm gonna go
pick you up when did you guys first like
learn to drive then did you learn how to
drive like immediately when you could
or did you yeah like when i complicated
story oh for me it was like the moment
you hit 16. was complicated about it
how did this be complicated so i started
learning how to drive when i was uh
17 which is when you do in the uk yeah
yeah yeah yeah but what sucks is that
because my birthday was in july which is
the end of the school year people who
who started in september had already
like way past got their cars and were
driving
it ends in july oh sorry ends in
september sorry september no it starts
to start starting to end in like august
yeah yeah what yeah really yeah yeah i i
don't know if we're talking about that
when is yours it's january
the school year starts in january yeah
what it ends in december starts in
january
okay so where how do some holidays work
for you then summer holidays is december
but then when do you get christmas
holidays
so you end so
actually it technically starts in
february so we end school middle of
december and then you celebrate
christmas and holidays during holidays
and then all of january's summer
holidays and then you come back how long
do you get off them during summer
holidays yeah like depends on the school
but like
usually like a month and a half okay
okay like
nearly three months because it's pretty
much
the first half of august is when it ends
right yeah yeah and then we're talking
university or we're talking like
secondary
section both are the same right yeah for
us it was all the same no no in
university i remember in university you
get like [ __ ] three months off and
those were like those that was like
before that
like school holidays for me were always
the summer holiday was six weeks it was
always six weeks winter holidays winter
holidays was two weeks and then we'd
have like half terms where you'd get
like
where you'd always where you'd get like
one week off like halfway through
spring and autumn yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so all together we got like
we got we almost got like about around
two months of holiday that was spread
yeah yeah and then like university here
and i remember thinking yo what the [ __ ]
we get three months off
for like f
we get three months off for summer why
am i even going to [ __ ] education
anymore man
the first time i experienced the first
like summer holidays in uni i was like
well
see you at university never again
i remember
i remember when some holiday started in
university i'm just like well i'm just
not gonna go back to uni yeah that's
three months right that's like you know
you know what you can't imagine the end
of some holiday yeah yeah
um but yeah so the point was that yeah
basically kids who are born in september
oh sorry [ __ ] am i saying i'm checking
my ass kids who had their birthday like
in my year who were like really close to
the start of the year yeah basically got
to have their license and already had it
right
right yeah [ __ ]
um and you were right at the end yeah so
yeah yeah so they were in my year
because it didn't matter through the
year above because you weren't friends
right yeah even if i was closer in age
technically so like the the people who
got it first were like the coolest ones
oh yeah because it was like everyone was
like oh can we get give me a left arm
because yeah yeah oh i'll drive you
there it's like yeah wait
is that is that way so it's like for for
in the uk
you guys have like different stages in
your driving license right like you have
like learners yeah with like provisional
stuff
so when you're on your first level
yeah
so you have it or you're learning okay
so when you're all learning can you just
like drive by yourself no no okay no you
you have to have someone in there you
need to be there someone who's
supervised yeah okay supervise you and
has how many years of experience x
amount of years right driving yeah and
you can't go on like the highways yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like it's only
until your provisionals that you can
drive by yourself right yeah yeah but
the problem is that normally not that
you can't find someone that you can't
get a car
yeah you're doing to be insured and that
was what the hard part was because
insurance for for like a 17 year old is
different
yeah you need to be insured no i could i
could just use my mom's car no you might
have had family insurance oh maybe i
don't know but like if yeah even if if
you are under family insurance your
price gets like tripled if you have a
life if you have a 17 year old on your
life yeah yeah it's insane like yeah the
reason why i was just like no one owned
a car except for a few people yeah was
because the insurance cost was like
triple or quadruple the car yeah right
right the car was nothing like my mate
got a car for like 100 quid off some guy
the insurance was like a thousand plus
yeah so it was like jesus it's yeah yeah
it was it was more cost for the
insurance than the car itself the
lessons were expensive as well i did
lessons my brother had already passed
and you know so it was my turn
i was doing it and it was going well and
then every now and then the guy would
just kind of call me up because i was
learning through a guy yeah that was how
you mainly learn in the at least the
countryside yeah okay and he was kind of
flaky he was kind of like he wouldn't
show up sometimes
and then sometimes he would just stop
and then
i'm i'm about i want to say two-thirds
away from getting my test and he just
calls up and he's like oh yeah by the
way uh i've quit i'm just not doing any
more i'm not doing i've i'm sorry that i
don't want to do it well instructing uh
people because the costs on the car are
too much and stuff yeah oh
oh okay uh all right well so i thought
it can't be too hard to find another one
my mom just could not find another
instructor because they're all booked up
because there's not many in my opinion
during your learning stage right yeah
yeah yeah normally like they're they get
booked up pretty quickly because there's
not that many because yeah very
profitable yeah it really like doesn't
make much money and it's a lot of work
um and it's a lot of upkeep on the car
as well yeah so
he did that and and then i couldn't i
couldn't find one for like
i want to say right up until like three
months before i was leaving for
university right so i had to get back
into it it'd been like a six seven
months cause i couldn't find anyone yeah
started doing it again and i was kind of
getting okay at it and i was maybe like
i don't know
i want to say like 10 lessons off
doing the test right i'd go to
university right and then i just didn't
do it yeah of course because like busy
having fun yeah because like and you
don't need a car in university
definitely yeah and um you know i
didn't have my license and then it
became something that i was kind of like
okay don't really want to do this
anymore because it's kind of in the way
yeah it's really pain in the ass and i
have to start from zero again and if i
did do it i thought i'll do one of those
like because you can do like week
intensive course yeah yeah you just
drive like eight hours a day yeah and
you do your test and hopefully you pass
statistically they're like the worst
drivers yeah but you know because you're
basically speed running driving yeah
yeah yeah so
so i you know i i'd gone through all of
uni never did it and at this point like
in the uk you have to have two things a
theory test and a practical test yeah
theory is really easy but it only lasts
two years after you've done it so mine
had expired right so i had to go and do
it again right yeah so i was in london
and i was like oh [ __ ] okay i'll go i'll
go and get it i'm gonna actually learn
to drive yeah and then i booked one of
these courses that was like really
expensive yeah for like five days yeah
and their like promise was you will
guaranteed get your license by day five
and anyone who says guarantees
guaranteed guaranteed to get a lot of
time
so i started driving yeah and i had this
guy and he was well
great as well she'll be really nice i
could bribe him
well he wasn't like he wasn't testing me
but
and you're also allowed to use that
person's car for the test and stuff
right you know it was really good he was
nice to start you know he was like oh
you're welsh good good i like wash
people we were both in london so it's
kind of like oh nice nice he was really
weird uh
he would also take any opportunity to
insult women drivers
and also you would sometimes you know
because you're in the car for like six
hours seven hours yeah right you know
you'd talk about life and stuff he would
bring up some things and he'd bring up
some of his his views on the world yeah
that you'd be like
yeah yeah yeah terrible
yeah
yeah situation can't stand it we're
parking by the way
where are we going
my dad uh my dad as well kind of has
like that weird like he creates these
like stereotypes out of nowhere when it
comes to like driving it's so we now do
no think about i'm like every time i
remember there were moments where like
my dad would be driving my dad will say
he doesn't have road rage he absolutely
[ __ ] up
like i don't care what he says because
every time i remember like every time
he'd be on the road and there'd just be
like someone who's like taking him off
for whatever reason he'd be like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] move and then he'd you
know get into the lane look and didn't
like do the luigi death stare yeah and
they'd be like oh it's [ __ ] volvo
drivers and i'm like i don't think
everybody knows all the dads do this i
don't think every volvo driver is
necessarily a bad driver like bmw
drivers like a massive [ __ ]
what is your personal vendetta against
volvo yeah because because like i
remember like the one of the biggest
stereotypes was like asians are like bad
drivers right yeah and like i don't i
don't think necessarily asians are bad
drivers i think asians just drive by the
rules of their own country exactly which
is just like a [ __ ] free-for-all you
know like i remember because like i
remember when uh when i first learned
how to drive i didn't actually first
learn how to drive uh in the uk yeah
right so i i believe like
turns up in the uk
yeah so so what happened is um so i was
like turning 17 that year so i could i
could uh learn how to drive in the uk
but i believe in thailand like uh you
can like start learning from like 16.
i'm not sure if that's i'm not sure the
exact age
but but i i remember i could legally get
lessons to learn how to drive so i was
just like right why when i get head
start on learning how to drive before i
start to drive in the uk so i go so i
start learning to drive
in thailand right in bangkok right
um and um
and it's like the dark souls of driving
yeah it's it's it's like the dark souls
of driving so like i take a few lessons
there and i get you know get pretty
confident in driving in bangkok with
thailand rules right so so you know i
can i can competently handle the car and
uh definitely comfortably handle traffic
you know what i mean uh and so i
remember
i go back to uk and i turn 17 and i sign
up for my first lesson um and then
i uh so the instructor turns up and uh
you know we just have a casual chat
before before we start driving
um and uh then he asked me oh have you
had like any experiences or did you like
use your provisional license or whatever
and i'm like yeah yeah yeah you know i
i've actually i have i've actually like
learned how to drive in thailand like i
said this like with confidence like i
know how to drive you know breaking it
yeah i know i'd drive a car i've uh i've
started to learn how to drive in uh
thailand you know i've pretty confident
on bangkok road so you know could you
repeat that
and so you know so you know
i'm pretty confident about it so so it's
like okay okay so let's let's get let's
get this first lesson started then and
so immediately i just drive off and you
go stop you've immediately failed
because i didn't check i didn't check my
mirrors
i know i know they they do this to be
like
they just want you to do it you don't
understand but like that the guy i had
right when i was doing this it's like he
couldn't just say you did something
wrong it had to be this whole ordeal
where he was like that's a really good
turn for a [ __ ]
it was like nothing could be every
single thing had to be packaged with an
insult it was like yeah that was really
good on the roundabout if you wanted to
kill someone if you're a woman
oh you check your mirrors like a woman
yeah he would do this all the time it
was so infuriating because i was just
trying to get good and every single time
i'd be like how was this he was like
that was great if you want to kill
someone right and i was like
just tell me how it was at least at
least for you it was just like not
checking your mirrors like my my
my uncle failed his first driving test
because he was like all right get in the
car check all the mirrors all right
let's drive off it's like stop you've
immediately failed you drove out the
exit
oh
all right so he literally got in the car
tomb and didn't even make it out of the
driveway and he was like you've
instantly failed come back tomorrow yeah
because it sucks i mean you do it don't
they yeah because like i remember when i
learned how to drive in england i
basically had to relearn driving
from like what i was taught in thailand
because in thailand they they teach you
like awareness and control but uh like
like vehicle control but like in the uk
it's all about here's the procedure
check mirror hey check mirror b
yeah yeah check your blindfolds i i get
it but like in in thailand it's just
like uh you you must learn to become
super saiyan ultra instincts this is how
you drive this is the best way to take a
hit from a car
if someone hits you on the head
it's how you curl up correctly they take
the least casualties
he's gonna inflict maximum damage on an
[ __ ]
so
i i i did this five day thing right
where we were going through it and i had
this guy and it was kind of a slog and i
remember i really didn't like doing it
because the guy was just like not he was
not fun yeah but also driving in london
sucks yeah it's like
it's like it's a going slow simulator
and stopping waiting giving way to
people like just it's not like driving
outside of the london like at all it's
completely different so so i'm doing
this and uh it's not like driving in
wales definitely no yeah we get to the
fifth day i'm like
so ready to like book the test he's like
no
i said what do you mean like you're not
ready yet not right and what do you mean
it's like five days guaranteed you're
gonna fail right now if you do it and
i'm like oh i'm like what do we do then
he's like well
shit's back like like he like loves it
oh yeah yeah i'm like i'm like he's like
yeah well you know you could uh
pay me in cash and i'll give you uh some
private lessons you know and i was like
oh
i was like oh i was like oh i was like
is that that okay he's like yeah it's
okay
according to me
and it was like conveniently like really
expensive oh wow i was like but i was
like well [ __ ] i need him to say yes so
that i can yeah yeah you won't do it
without him so you literally bribed him
no no no no no no he he kind of
blackmailed oh yeah
yeah like no choice yeah i can't do the
lesson without him agreeing right yeah
so i was like oh and i was like well
when do we do it because i kind of
wanted to get this over and done with i
got to go to america and like oh yeah i
wanted to like get this done and he was
like oh um well you free tomorrow and i
was like yeah i'm free tomorrow and he
was like all right well meet me in this
this
car park tomorrow and we'll do like
three hours and then we'll see how you
do yeah so i pay him an extortionate
amount of money and you know and then we
do the three hours like all right now
you're ready and i'm like yeah
of course of course you're ready now you
probably just let me drove around for
the hour so isn't illegally a bribe or
something so um we he finally does it
and uh the way that this works normally
in the uk if you want to test i don't
know how it's in australia but you have
to wait like a month yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah but because i don't know how
they do it but this company has like an
in with the government where basically
like if anyone cancels they get all
those reservations oh so you basically
have to just be ready right and they'll
be like are you free tomorrow to do the
test yeah right so that's what happened
so i i i said i'm ready to get the test
and then like one day later they were
like come to this place at this time uh
the teacher will will be there and i was
like oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] nerve-wracking
now we have to go to like for all of our
tests you have to go to like a
government certified like road
really weird like beat up room it's just
one room what and like there's like
seven other people in here yeah and i
just turn off and i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's so weird right it looks like some
government building it like doesn't look
it's just above like a salon a chicken
shop so i go in and they're like did you
park the car so there's no car park in
this place either right park on the
street right so i'm i'm parked on a hill
upwards yeah right right and so i'm on
like a right before like are you're a
manual right yeah manually so i'm i'm
parked on a hill right before roundabout
and it's a really busy dual carriageway
yeah this is awful right that's like
nightmare this is literally like yeah
yeah yeah so i'm bricking it and he's
and this guy can tell i'm i'm freaking
out because it's a horrible start yeah
if you let it roll back at all like yeah
you fall down the hill
you fell immediately yeah and normally
like most driving like things you might
not even have to do this thing you start
from a hill so i was like [ __ ] i've
because my instructor decided the park
here this is where i had to start yeah
so i was like [ __ ] so so you know i'm
doing it and i i i'm i'm really [ __ ]
i let go of the the break and i'm just
not moving i'm not maintaining it and i
slowly start to creep and then it's
[ __ ] laurie just go down and that
goes past me i'm ah i'm freaking out
like
i'm like holding on to the clutch like
not letting it go because i don't want
to go and i don't want to fall down yeah
i'm just like sweating and he's like
wait calm down mate what are you doing
you
london and i was like oh yeah thanks man
i'm real calm now yeah
luckily i get going it's really easy you
know everything's going well and this
guy looks like he's falling asleep he's
literally like this
and i did a thing where i thought i
failed and then i was like oh [ __ ] i was
freaking out cause i thought i failed
halfway through and i go to the end and
um yeah i passed i did like one minor
mistake that was all i had don't know
how because on the way to the test i ran
a red light i did all things wrong and
everything went terribly and then um
yeah weirdly at the end of it my
instructor came up the guy who is like
really weird he came over and he was
like i thought he failed and i was like
why would you say that
he's like you know how i know i thought
you failed and i was like how and he's
like you know when the guy opens the
door before he gives the news it's not a
bad sign i'm like why why why would that
be a bad sign why does that make any
sense i don't understand why so he can
run away why is it like trying to like
psychoanalyze it sounds like a
actually a really nice instructor he was
like he was like uh he was like a proud
dad he was like i knew you'd probably
but the thing is my dad was my
instructor your dad was yours yeah
because in australia you don't when
you're on your learners you don't have
to go to lessons if you don't want no
you don't have to in the uk yeah it's
just like my parents so my parents are
like no that's [ __ ] expensive you're
not going to lessons
like son i'll teach you and i was like
dad you are literally the most crazy
[ __ ] driver i've known yeah because
most people when they drive they don't
drive like how they 100 should yeah
my parents wanted to teach me because
they were like we're probably not doing
something's right ourselves i was like
dad we're we're in an 80 zone and i'm
doing a hundred is this okay and he's
like
that's what he's like and he's like no
it's like no everyone else is doing it
they can't arrest all of us
that's true
yeah that's true that's fair enough
can i do this in the test yeah can i say
don't do it in the test but you'll be
right now driving is way more fun when
you've passed your test because you're
like okay i can kind of like relax like
oh this is like what is like driving
stressless now yeah yeah exactly i
actually remember the first time i was
like in the seat of a car actually so um
in the driver's seat of a car was
actually
when i was about like i think like 12 or
13. so like i remember like there was
there was one day where i think there
was like like a friend of a cousin who
was just like you know he was like very
rich so they like their family owned
like a lot of land right a lot of land
and so
um on some of this land that they owned
right um they let they let this kid they
let their kids uh drive around like
drive around like a drive around a car
it was like a beaten up car that's right
it was it was a beating up right um and
i remember going to this place once and
i was like and he was like driving
around his field i was like dude this is
badass and he was like you want to go
want to go and i was like
me
me 12 years old driving
am i like can you even see out the front
am i allowed to do that am i allowed to
do that he was like yeah it's private
land it's legal it's legal and i was
like 12 year old knew the concept of
private land
oh yeah of course the article is 1340.
well that's what it does that's what his
dad taught
um and so like and so i'm like i'm like
i go in the driver's seat and i start
like [ __ ] [ __ ] myself oh yeah
because i'm because i'm just like i'm
i'm in a [ __ ] car old choice like a
12 year old
as a 12 year old in the seat of a car it
doesn't matter if you're like driving a
jeep or a mini it's like [ __ ]
operating a gundam like oh no it it is
terrifying it is terrifying yeah i
remember the first [ __ ] thing i did
and he he was just like oh just
just tap the pedal a bit right
as a 12 year old i don't know what tap
means right
and so i'm just like i go what i think
is like uh is i i thought tapping it was
going 50 of the way down yeah you do you
do
so i'm like okay i'm going to tap this
i'm not going to put it all the way just
half the way like immediately i will
start put it half the way and i
immediately crash into his gates right
oh no
luckily it's like an old wooden gate and
it's like in the middle of [ __ ] up
well like but [ __ ] nowhere right like
i smash into this gate right and i i
start freaking out and he was like all
right get out of the driver's seat
never again
i like that i think that put me off
driving like for like well obviously i
was scared of the concept of driving
like like that one experience i think i
remember now yeah like the first time i
ever got into car seat was probably
around that age as well like 12 13 yeah
when we went camping yeah and like you
know because you're in a camping field
right not a lot of like and especially
when you're in a big camping field and
there's no one else there it's just a
lot of like really empty flat land so my
dad was like son
why not you wanna you wanna take it for
a spin
and i was like sure dad
i get in and i get in the seat and in my
head i'm like yeah this is gonna be easy
there's literally nothing around
except one
tree oh no
but like like any any person will tell
you it's like just don't go towards the
tree just go to this entire open area
where there is nothing
and in my head i was like okay just
don't go over to the tree what do i do
immediately go towards the tree did your
dad not like pull the wheel oh yeah he
did oh okay he was like son
did you hit it no i didn't
oh my god dude i wouldn't be alive if i
hit the tree i think my dad would kill
me yeah my dad would 100 yeah
but like i i don't know what it was it
was like in my 12 year old stupid 12
year old head
in the entire time i was like don't go
towards the tree don't go towards the
tree my hands are like go towards trees
okay
i uh accidentally flipped my friend's
quad bike over oh my that's dangerous
yeah that was dangerous we're riding
quad bikes in like the mud and i was
like this is the coolest [ __ ] thing
ever yeah like you know i was like 12.
yeah and then he was out he was like
don't go too fast though and i'm i'm i
was like a danger kid i would just like
love going too fast yeah [ __ ] like that
and uh yeah i think they also call that
an idiot
listen i should have been i should have
won a darwin award yeah yeah and so i'm
like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] quad but i start doing like
uh donuts with this quad bike right and
then yeah it just flips over and i flip
it but i'm so small that like i like get
down in the arch like when i fall to the
side like don't hit my head or anything
because like yeah i think like quad bike
accidents like deaths like a very calm
yeah it wasn't like super fast it was
just me being stupid and turning but i
just fell off jesus christ
dangerous dangerous yeah don't do that
don't don't don't flip bikes yeah yeah
because like i remember i remember i
like i i never like i had i knew one
person in my school who owned like a
quad bike and he was like the [ __ ]
cool kid right if you have like farms
everyone like like a lot of people had
them yeah i mean like the only reason
this guy this uh this guy the quad bike
or this kid out of the quarterback was
because his dad had won the lottery
right so he was like he was why is it
when you get too rich you buy a quadrant
i don't know because there's no
practical for a quad bike right right
it's just to have if you have too much
land you get a quad bike so you can get
around the land
yeah so he was just like he was the cool
kid because he was the kid that owned a
quad bike and like it was like the kid
that like you'd want to be friends
because you knew that you'd made it when
he'd invite you around his house yeah
because like you'd hear you'd hear
stories about how people went to this
kid's house and like i went on a quad
bike
it's either that one kid that owns a
quad bike or that one kid whose dad
works in an i.t company and owns every
game console oh yeah everyone had that
one friend
my friend was both oh really oh my god
his dad was a song
that was a farmer so he had all the quad
bike and all that stuff but he also had
all the game consoles and i always used
to love going because he had pokemon
colosseum on the gamecube oh best game
and i was like this is insane you can
the pokemon are like 3d
what
so we'd have a day of like quad biking
and then
his mom would make amazing food and then
yeah
yeah and so i just like never wanted to
leave his house and luckily like i slept
slept over this house so many goddamn
giants yeah i loved staying at his house
yeah i had that one friend too that was
like amazing it was so much fun i loved
i loved going to his house that was like
the best child of memories yeah except
where i knew he died on the quad bank of
course that was my own fault
that was my own fault that's fair enough
but bikes are fun though yeah
there was really
so fun
they're pretty easy to drive have i been
on one i don't think i have been on one
actually it's like a stable bike
until it flips over absolutely yeah it's
gonna do a dumb turn i mean so like that
we used to go to like the you know what
i was saying about like the kayaking
thing yeah there was another place that
was kind of a similar thing had like
swimming pool and all that and it also
had quad bikes are you allowed to ride
but they put like safety pins or
something in it that limited the speed
so you couldn't go above a certain speed
and it was painfully slow yeah and one
of the kids who owned the quad bike knew
how to remove it right and then so we
were all doing laps right going really
slow on these bikes
it suddenly is this one kid's turn and
the teachers are like looked away for a
second and they go back this kid's going
like [ __ ] tearing up all the like
dirt just flinging it and all the
teachers and stuff like actually tearing
up the track and they couldn't stop him
right because he's going too fast yeah
you could like get in the way yeah and
so he's going super fast he gets the
ball king of his life but he's so funny
just watching him like destroy this this
like land that had been finally made it
was just like tearing up the mud and
[ __ ] destroy it all so funny do you guys
have any experiences uh with motorbikes
or anything like that no i i wish i'd
love to drive them i've been on the back
of a motorbike many times but it's it's
scary it's [ __ ] terrifying i want to
learn how to ride one
i've thought about it but then i've also
heard of every single person i've ever
known who used to ride a motorbike is
it's all past tense they used to ride a
motorbike because most of the time they
get in horrible accidents i just want to
ride one i want to know how to drive one
what if i'm like i just need to ride a
motorcycle one day i was like
i was tempted to get like uh in japan
like getting like a boathead license
because apparently you can get it in
like one day right it's like yeah you
just have to do like a test and you pay
like 60 bucks or something yeah 60 60
sucks
16 bucks
yeah you pay like 60 bucks for a test
and then you can just get it in like a
couple of hours yeah you just have to
buy or if you like james bond chase you
need to drive a motorcycle you know i'm
going to drive my moped [ __ ]
stop you immediately where you going
yeah
because like like if you go to thailand
you're probably going to have to ride a
motorcycle
when i say motorcycle it's not like a
[ __ ] harley davidson or something
it's it's it's the southeast asian like
kind of like moped motorcycles where
it's like a scooter right like a scooter
yeah i thought motocross was really cool
as well right yeah like like like that
kind of like that kind of bike i guess
yeah but like i've been on on enough
[ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] mo like moped
motorbike taxi drivers that it's just
put me off from ever wanting to learn a
motorbike and like the one time that i
tried learning how to ride a motorbike
which was one of these bikes mind you
and i remember of course it was in
thailand and uh like i remember like if
you want to get around but not want to
own a car then you'd learn how to drive
a motorcycle right that's that's the
cheap way to go about it i mean that's
why in top gear and the vietnam special
they didn't have cars they had
motorbikes right they stole them huh
they get stolen a lot i assume i've
never owned one so i would assume so
probably right but like i remember like
the only time i've tried to learn how to
ride one was i was i was i've had like
enough like scary experience with
motorbikes that i've just never wanted
to learn
and i remember like i remember my dad
was just like come on you gotta learn
how to drive come on we're in town you
gotta learn how
and i remember he like builds this i'd
like my entire family like build this
idea up of me having to like at least
give it a try of how to learn how to
ride a motorbike and i remember this one
time
i was like okay fine i'll give it i'll
give it a try i'll give it a try it's
just like like it's just like riding a
bike right it's just like riding a bike
right now i'm just like just like riding
a bike and it's it was like a
one-for-one recreation of like my car
experience right
because i remember i remember my dad
after building up all this courage we
have uh we have like my uh we have like
my cousin's motorbike that i could try
out and just start learning with and my
dad like brings me over to the bike and
goes okay just sit on this bike okay and
what you need to do just just try just
try like just like give you that much
confidence he's like stuck you on it
yeah he stopped me on it and he just
like he just twisted it he just just
twisted a bit just give it a bit of a
rev and me like like a one for one
thinking a little bit of a bit of a
twist is fifty percent of water
okay i'll give it a little twist 50
power
like that immediately
rev forward i immediately fall down and
like the motorbike falls down on me i'm
like all right no i'm never getting on
one again
i'm just reminded of all those videos of
like where they thank you where they
like rev the motorbike
just over them yeah i don't know i
really want to learn like i don't know
like a lot of quote unquote like
dangerous vehicles i'd love to learn how
to drive i really want to learn how to
drive a speedboat i don't know why i've
never
even been in like a speech boat i've
been in a speedboat i've never been in
the street i just want to learn how to
drive one i look so funny because in
australia or at least in sydney we used
to have uh like we had like a ferry
service because we were like in a bay
but you'd also get what's called uh a
water cat which is basically think of
like
it's a tactic i think i know like a
water taxi but it's instead of a taxi
it's a speed boat yeah i think i know
the one and you get on both of them dude
those things are [ __ ] scary they look
so funny they're so fast like i want to
ride a jet ski i've never ridden jet ski
in my life i want to write a jet ski
because i thought jet skis are fun
that's like the college frat boy [ __ ]
yeah i just want to ride one it looks so
fun yeah still a student in thailand
yeah
it's very very easy to get jet skis in
thailand yeah i remember saw a sheet
that was like
it was like accidents by race or
something right it was like 100 of
accidents in like some part of the us
was like all white people or something
and it was it was for it was for uh jet
ski yeah 100 of jet ski accidents for
white people and i was like yeah yeah
that makes sense let's see
that checks out yeah that checks out i
think the second was like skiing or
something oh yeah okay was third golf
i've always wanted to try surfing
surfing was one thing i've always wanted
to try i've done surfing and i'm talking
of course you're australian joey right
i thought i would enjoy it but i weirdly
didn't it seems really hard it's really
really hard um it's not even so much
about like you know it's not like
snowboarding where like the biggest
obstacle is you're being scared to just
like go fast or whatever like it's
literally just like
it's the act of
standing up
from a really like rickety like where
the floor isn't still right and like
that and you do that a couple of times
and you can't even like get on your
knees and then you [ __ ] fall over and
then you're hot you you just snap you're
like [ __ ] it i can't do it because like
the one time you can actually like stand
up yeah it's actually pretty easy to
control right right because just think
of it like snowboarding but with less
friction right so it's pretty easy to do
it's the standing up part that's like
[ __ ] impossible for me i don't know
what it is um and then when you when you
flip in
a in a surfboard it hurts yeah i can
imagine because the one thing that i'm
always afraid of is like what if i flip
off on the ball and then the board just
[ __ ] smacks off yeah yeah yeah like
i've seen that happen to people yeah
looks like a really [ __ ] hug seeing
them ride that wave is just so [ __ ]
cool
again i've never had the opportunity
like living in england where are we
going to find [ __ ] waves
you could go to cornwall i know but they
died
the ways that waves are way too powerful
yeah
like nothing i think that was the
problem as well because like you know
because we did it for pe at one time
because because our score's rising the
most australian thing i've ever heard oh
because our school's laughing for pe
because the school is literally next to
a beach so you just like walk down five
minutes down the hill and it's like yeah
there's a beach right there yes earth um
of course there is yeah but it's
scary dude for a different reason that's
so cool i wish i could i wish i could
what's the first we want to try you want
to try golf you want to try sailing
surfing surfing and sailing i want to
try quad biking yeah dude
yeah i got a taste of adrenaline you
know
bungee jumping yeah i'm still waiting
for chris
but you know who else likes extreme
sports our patrons of course of course i
don't know i don't know daring they
dared enough to support them yeah
they're social that is the most extreme
sport it's the support a podcast that's
supporting getting yourself out getting
the wallet out that's the hardest sport
thinking yeah these guys are worth my
money that's that's the most extreme
sport we appreciate would you appreciate
it yes but thank you and if you would
like to support the show then go to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us some memes on the
subreddit and if you had our face listen
to us on spotify um and what kind of
extreme sport would you like to try i
feel like this pandemic like era has
just like made people want to just like
try sport at least for me anyway yeah
because because the i think one of the
biggest things about trying new sport is
just getting like getting the motivation
to just go out of your comfort zone go
out of your comfort zone and just try
out and use it it definitely helps when
you have a like your mates around and be
like yeah yeah with you yeah exactly
exactly like i don't know if i could do
snowboarding by myself because i just
feel like yeah
there's this it's a sad image of just
like one person just sitting in the
[ __ ] thing
right it's like oh
anyway that's been this episode of trash
taste
good see you guys next week i guess bye
[Music]
you